Um es mit den Worten von einem gewissen Marc S zu sagen, die zweite Liga ist so weg. Und wir sind es auch. Marc und ich sprechen jetzt über die neue Saison in der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer und stellen euch das neue Format vor. Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben! Kroffi zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner!
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo Leute, ist das schön, wieder dieses Intro zu hören. Ich hab's vermisst und damit herzlich willkommen zurück bei der Ligatour. Ich bin Eva Lottabohle. Ich bin 50% vom Moderator in dem Team der Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ihr könnt mich sonst noch bei 11 Freunde am Abend hören. Und ich freue mich wirklich, wirklich sehr, dass es heute zu einer Mini-Premiere in diesem Format kommt. Denn ich darf endlich an meiner Seite die anderen 50% des Teams begrüßen. Marc Schwitzki, hallo!
Ich grüße dich, Eva. Ja, das war die einzige Schattenseite, dass wir dieses Projekt angetreten sind, war, dass quasi wir nicht mehr zusammen aufgenommen haben, weil wir dann ja jeweils die Sendung moderiert haben. Heute haben wir es ein bisschen anders gestaltet zum Start dieser 2. Liga, die ja wirklich, also es war ein Feuerwerk. Ich würde sagen, du hast mich richtig zitiert, die 2. Liga ist back. Wir haben schon wieder alles gesehen. Krasse Tore, WIA-Entscheidungen, alles. Und ich freue mich richtig doll, dass wir dieses 2. Liga ja wieder zusammen begleiten werden.
Ja, da gehe ich komplett mit. Aber bevor wir reinstarten, natürlich ein bisschen Housekeeping vorweg und im Zuge natürlich, wie immer, der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch euch HörerInnen und er lebt tatsächlich auch durch euch HörerInnen. Stellvertretend wollen wir dafür heute Danke sagen an Gset, unterstrich Adler Marcel Juli und André R aus H. Vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und natürlich wollen wir uns auch ganz, ganz herzlich bei euch bedanken für die lieben Worte und die konstruktive Kritik in der HörerInnen-Umfrage des Rasenfunks. Es freut uns wirklich sehr, dass es ja bei einem Großteil von euch bisher so gut angekommen sind, dass Marc und ich als Team hier quasi zusammenkommen und dass wir auch bei euch gut ankommen und wollen euch in dem Zuge aber tatsächlich auch nochmal ermutigen, wenn ihr konstruktive Kritik habt und ihr das vielleicht nicht öffentlich machen wollt, was ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung ist, nutzt auch sonst auch gerne die DM-Funktion entweder bei Blue Sky oder im Forum. Da freuen wir uns sehr auch immer über Feedback und sonst dürft ihr auch gerne immer beim Input zur Ligatour was beisteuern. Den Link habe ich euch nochmal in die Show Notes gepackt und vielleicht noch eine ganz kleine Entschuldigung, dass es am Ende keinen ja großen Saisonabschluss gab zur letzten Saison. Wir hatten es überlegt, glaube ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich glaube wir waren beide auch ein bisschen durch. Ja, ja doch. Man muss dann natürlich auch immer überlegen, hat es dann wirklich so ein Mehrwert hinten raus und wir hatten irgendwie so das Gefühl, wir hatten schon relativ viel dann doch drüber gesprochen, vor allem in der großen Folge zum Abschluss, die Marc gemacht hatte. Deshalb, wie gesagt, entschuldigt uns da bitte. So, kleineren Ausblick darauf, was ihr heute eigentlich so von uns bekommt. Wir wollen damit beginnen, euch das neue Format vorzustellen und zu erklären. Und dann wagen wir uns entlang des ersten Spieltags, eine kleine Vorschau auf die Saison. Ganz darauf sollt ihr nämlich nicht verzichten, und geben mal so ein bisschen unsere Prognosen ab. Also so ein bisschen, was ihr vielleicht aus der Bundesliga der Männer Vorschau Sendung könnt. Keine Angst, nicht im gleichen Umfang. Aber wir wollen so ein bisschen gucken, naja, wer wird denn besser, wer wird gleich, wer wird vielleicht schlechter performen als im Jahr davor. Und wir wollen natürlich auch euch, auch nicht, unsere Auf- und Absteigertipps vorenthalten. Und da können wir uns…
Die Altern bei mir übrigens nach einem Spieltag schon fantastisch, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das ist… also das hat ja wirklich absolut gar nichts zu bedeuten. Das wissen wir doch alle. Und da kann ich ja mal ganz kurz spoilern. Da tritt unser All-Star-Team. Was das ist, das erklärt Marc euch gleich. Auch erstmals in der Scheinung, da schon mal den Hinweis, da ganz, ganz aufmerksam mal auf unsere sozialen Kanäle gucken, was das denn für Tipps hinterher sind. Und dann ja, Bühne frei, Marc.
Jawoll. Zweitligerexpertinnen, wir haben das Wort jetzt schon quasi benutzt oder All-Stars. Und ich höre euch doch schon fragen, was ist denn das jetzt genau? Ja, ja, das hängt mit der Formatänderung zusammen. Wir wollten die Zweitligersendung zukünftig nach dem Vorbild der Ligatur Europa gestalten, die Max ja so wunderbar moderiert immer wieder. Und die ja ja so ein kleines Liebling geworden ist, habe ich auch das Gefühl, der Rasenfunk Community, soll heißen, wir haben nun ein festes Team aus 2. Liga-FachkennnerInnen, mit denen wir die Sendung personell bestücken werden. Also es ist weiterhin so, alle 2 Wochen eine Sendung moderiert Eva, eine ich, oder wenn mal Temminifers da dazwischenkommt, kann sich das natürlich auch mal doppeln. Und 2 Gäste, die aber, wie gesagt, aus diesem festen Pool kommen werden. Wir trennen uns also davon, jede Folge unbedingt sklavisch 2 Vereine besprechen zu müssen. So und alle auch gleichmäßig rankommen zu lassen. Denn wir kennen, dass die 2. Liga und generell der Fußball bietet nun mal immer wieder andere Themen. Und es hat dann oft gar nicht sich so passend angefühlt, nach einem Spieltag, wo sonst was passiert ist, dann doch die feste Liste gefühlt abzuarbeiten, weil man das ja so festgelegt hatte. Wir wollen also aktueller und näher an den Geschehnissen des Spieltags bleiben. So können wir dann weitaus flexibler und auch aktueller sein, was vor allem euch Höhren zu gut kommen soll. Wie gesagt, wir werden da auch nicht einfach jeden Spieltag durchbesprechen, wie in so einer Schlusskonferenz. Auch da wollen wir gucken, was denn die drei, vier Themen des Spieltags oder der letzten zwei Wochen sind. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja einen zwei-Wochen-Rhythmus. Was sind da die aktuellsten Entwicklungen und worauf muss man besonders gucken? Ich möchte euch das All-Star-Team natürlich vorstellen, die Rasenfunk Avengers, wie ich sie zwischenzeitlich getauft habe. Es sind dabei Anna Lautenbach, Kevin Bublitz, Lisa Höfer, Matthias Kneifel, Moritz Kreilinger, Michael Fischer, Nele Hüpper, Thomas Haufe und Tobi Rieger. Expertinnen verschiedenster Vereine. Wir haben versucht, ein möglichst breites Spektrum abzubilden, dass wir auch in allen Tabellenregionen immer mal wieder eine Expertin dabei haben können oder eben auch, was große Traditionsvereine angeht. Ich würde aber auch sagen, wenn es das mega super heiße Topthema gäbe und das betrifft Elversberg, dann kann ja vielleicht auch noch mal jemand extra dazu kommen, aber eigentlich sollte es dabei erst mal bleiben. Ich freue mich unglaublich darauf. Die haben alle gefühlt in der ersten Sekunde zugesagt, sind heiß und dementsprechend ja grunderneut wie Hannover 96 gehen wir in diese Saison.
Das hast du sehr schön gesagt und da gehen natürlich auch wirklich noch mal Grüße raus und ein großes Danke, das ist nicht selbstverständlich, dass sich da so schnell so ein Team zusammengefunden hat. Und wir können glaube ich einfach für Marc und mich erleichtert das auch vieles, auch viel hinter den Kulissen, weil es dann doch mal auch relativ kurzfristig wurde und man natürlich dann in diesen Vereinstruktur so ein bisschen festgefahren war. Von daher freuen wir uns da sehr drauf und sind auch sehr gespannt, wie euch das dann gefällt. Aber wir wollen jetzt auch nicht zu viel darüber diskutieren, wie ist das neue Format etc. Sondern wir wollen tatsächlich jetzt auch mal wirklich ans Eingemachte gehen. Und ich habe es eben schon gesagt, wir wollen da so ein bisschen auf den ersten Spieltag blicken. Das wird jetzt keine klassische Spieltagsbesprechung, aber wir haben gedacht, es ist irgendwie einfacher, um da so eine gewisse Struktur zu haben und Marc, du hast es schon gesagt, also torreich. Wir haben 30 Tore gesehen an diesem ersten Spieltag. Wir haben acht Heimsiege, ein Aussaussieg, kein Unentschieden. Wie man ja so schön sagt, für die neutralen Zuschauerinnen war das ein erfolgreicher Spieltag. Und genau, wir wollen jetzt den Spieltag entlanggehen, von Freitag bis Sonntag bis heute und dann so ein bisschen unsere Miniprognosen abgeben. Und ich würde sagen, Marc, wir legen mal direkt den Finger in die Wunde. Starte doch bitte rein.
Jaja, am Freitagabend ging es los. Schalke und Hertha eröffneten die Zweitligasaison. Schalke, Hertha, über 60.000 Zuschauer. Das war wirklich wieder Erstligaflare. Das hatte wieder alles. Und nach 23 Minuten war die Nummer quasi schon wieder durch. Durch Tore von Silla und Neuzugang Kartic führte Schalke, das wie entfesselt auftrat, bereits 2 zu 0. Hertha ließ sich vom D-Zug, der von Neutrainer Miron Muzlic gesteuert wurde, regelrecht überrennen, konnte diese Intensität, obwohl die zu erwarten war, nicht mitgehen. Im zweiten Durchgang hat Hertha das etwas beruhigen können. Schalke hat sich aber auch etwas zurückgezogen und das dauerte bis zu 89. Minute. So schlimm war es nicht. 89. Minute bis dann Neuzugang Sebastian Gröning bei Hertha, den– das muss man mal sagen– sehr sehenswerten Anschlusstreffer erzielt hat. Das geht ein bisschen, oder?
Definitiv, ja.
Schönes Hackentor, ja, aber trotz dieser etwas größeren Spielkontrolle wurde man bis dahin eben überhaupt nicht gefährlich. Klar, dann wird es nochmal ein bisschen hektisch, kartisch, der einen Kopftreffer abbekommen hatte. Auch vielleicht genau deswegen benutzt seine Hand eine Kopfball-Duell, fliegt doch noch vom Platz, nimmt an dem Spiel wirklich auch alles mit als Neuzugang, muss man sagen. Und ja, trotzdem bringt Schalke das über die Zeit. Das ist ein Auftakt nach Mars für die Königsblauen und ein erster Herber, Dämpfer für Hertha, das ja durch die Bank das Zielaufstieg ausgerufen hat und dementsprechend auf jeden Fall zwei sehr unterschiedliche emotionale Welten nach Abpfiff.
Ja, also als Ergänzung natürlich nochmal diese ganze Cartridge-Sache hat natürlich auch nochmal, ja, so diese ganze Krux der Kopfballverletzung im Fußball. Ganz gut aufgezeigt, also die ganzen Stimmen, die danach, Kommentare, die danach auch rumflogen, auch von Schalker Seite, waren jetzt nicht, ja, ich glaube, besonders glücklich gewählt. Das muss Lig, glaube ich. Also, dass das, ich glaube, das Erzeteam.
Man hat sich da auf Verantwortung genommen, finde ich. Man hat sich auf den Schiedsrichter gespannt gelegt.
Genau. Und ich glaube, das Erzeteam hat sogar eigentlich gesagt, er soll nicht und dann soll sich auch Cartridge selber irgendwie wieder angemeldet haben. Also, es ist alles nicht einfach. Und eigentlich befürwortet es ja, dass sowas, sobald Kopfverletzungen im Spiel sind, ja, wirklich eigentlich dazu gehört, dass es da eine unparteiliche Seite gibt, die am Ende eben nicht nur eine Empfehlung abgibt, sondern ehrlich gesagt auch zugunsten der Gesundheit der Spieler wirklich da die Entscheidung trifft. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig. Ich habe es auch gesehen.
Ein sehr leidiges, altes Thema einfach auch.
Ja, ich habe es gesehen. Es wurde im inoffiziellen Rasenfunk-Discord auch durchaus lang und breit diskutiert. Zeigt ja auch, wie wichtig das ist, ne? Und wie, ja.
Gut.
Man muss ja sagen, wir wollen so eine kleine Einschätzung hören. Und ich würde einfach mal tatsächlich mit der Hertha anfangen.
Gerne.
Wenn das in der Hertha kommt.
Du bist natürlich ein bisschen näher dran und ich mache mich vielleicht bei einigen Hertha-Fans direkt unbeliebt. Weil, ich sage, Hertha performt besser als letzte Saison. Das liegt vor allem an vielen guten Kaderergänzungen, also generell ein fitter Riese. Es gibt natürlich immer einen absoluten Wucht da vorne drin. Mit Kovnatsky, absoluter Kandidat, der da was reißen kann. Und Gröning war natürlich so ein 50-50-Deal von Ingolstadt. Also sehr interessante Spieler, vor allem in der Offensive. Es war natürlich so ein bisschen die Frage, gut, Masa weg ist Kartenbacher zu ersetzen. Mein Problem ist mit Hertha. Und deshalb, also bei vielen Expertinnen, ja auch absoluter Ausstiegsfavorit. Ich kann schon mal verraten, 10 von unserem Oldster-Team haben Hertha unter den ersten drei. Nur zwei Personen nicht. Das bin ich und Max-Jakob Ost, der hat nämlich netterweise mitgetimpt, der gute Mann. Weil bei mir das Problem ist, dadurch, dass Hertha natürlich auch so offensiv gesagt hat, wir wollen aufsteigen und wir müssen ehrlich gesagt auch aufsteigen, ist der Druck einfach da. Und sie gehen in jedem Spiel natürlich irgendwie als Favorit, ob sie das wollen oder nicht. Oder bei ihnen ist direkt der Spotlight drauf. Und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass– ja, ich verstehe, woher das kommt, dass es so offensiv auch nach draußen zu tragen. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass man da dem Verein und dem Kader auch keinen sonderlich großen Gefallen getan hat, da irgendwie vor dem ersten Spieltag sowas auszudrücken. Aber ich muss natürlich auch sagen, Marc, du bist um einiges näher dran. Das ist einfach nur mein äußerer Eindruck.
Und der ist ja auch legitim. Das ist definitiv eine Lesart. Ich finde die offensive Zielformulierung sehr gut, denn ich habe besonders letzte Saison das Gefühl gehabt, dass genau dieses Rumeiern, was Hertha da praktiziert hat, da hatte man noch gesagt, ja, wir möchten eines der Teams sein, das oben mit dabei ist. Was ich in der 2. Liga irgendwie schwierig finde, weil du kannst ja nicht Sechser werden und dann europäisch spielen, also entweder spielst du um den Aufstieg oder nicht, das hat sich durch die Saison gezogen und hat der Mannschaft, wie ich finde, eher ein Alibi gegeben, weil man selbst nach 2-3. Saison noch sagen konnte, ja, aber wenn wir jetzt eine Serie starten, haben wir ja den Anschluss und dann sieht es ja nicht mehr so schlecht aus. Jetzt weiß man, woran man ist im Ziel. Und ehrlich gesagt, ein anderes Ziel kannst du, wie ich finde, mit dem Kader auch nicht mehr verkaufen. Hertha hat, wie ich finde, den individuell besten Kader der Liga. Sicherlich ist es kein perfekter Kader, aber den kriegst du in der 2. Liga auch nicht. Also ich würde sagen, du hast nach wie vor ein Problem auf der linken Schiene. Das hat sich auch gegen Schalke gezeigt mit Karbovnik. Du hast mit Jagd Ernst einer der eher unsicheren Keeper dieser 2. Liga. Aber insgesamt mit Spielern wie Reze, Cuisance, Kownazki, Krattenmacher hast du Unterschiedsspieler. Du hast sehr viele erfahrene Spieler. Du hast deine Achse halten können. Das ist ja auch frühzeitig. Also Hertha's Kader stand so früh wie kaum ein anderer in der 2. Liga, würde ich behaupten, weil du ja auch Transfers wie Jensen, Gröning und Kolbe sehr, sehr früh in der Tasche hattest. Und dementsprechend ja auch gewisse Abgänge durchaus früh hast kompensieren können. Ja, die Abgänge von Scherhand, Maser und auch John-John Kenny muss man wirklich nennen. Das war der beste Rechtsverteidiger der Liga. Die wiegen schwer. Niederlechner wiegt auch menschlich schwer. Aber ich finde, an sich hast du das gut kompensiert. Und du hast einen Trainer mit Stefan Leitel, der in den letzten Jahren eigentlich immer erfolgreich war. Der ist mit 4. sehr überraschend aufgestiegen, weiß dementsprechend auch, wie es geht. Der ist mit Hannover kurz vorm Ziel nochmal weggegrätscht worden von den Verantwortlichen, wie ich finde. Also ich finde, die Hinrunde von Hannover letzte Saison unter Leitel war grundsolide und du hättest aufsteigen können. Und naja, die Rückrunde hat ja bewiesen, dass das vielleicht nicht der beste Move war, ihn gehen zu lassen. So, und diese– also die Rückrunde mit Andre Breitenreiter ist jetzt nicht so gut gealtert.
Bleibt die Frage, ob es an Andre Breitenreiter lage oder am Kader von Hannover 96.
Ja, gut, aber dann ist die Frage, war es so klug, Stefan Leitel in diesem 3-Jahres-Projekt nach zweieinhalb Jahren gehen zu lassen. Aber sei es drum, das heißt, ich finde, also Hertha-Fans sind sehr gebrannte Kinder, was Hoffnung angeht, weil das eigentlich immer Schmerzen bedeutet. Und man wollte sich nicht so richtig trauen, als Hertha-Fan und Beobachter zu sagen, jo, jetzt packen Sie es, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, das Alter ist natürlich schlechter Satz, nach diesem Schalke-Spiel, aber mir gingen stückweit die Argumente dafür aus, warum es nicht klappen soll. Eben auch, weil ich finde, Köln aufgestiegen, der HSV aufgestiegen, die Liga ist, finde ich, oben in der Spitze noch enger zusammengerückt. Und ich, deswegen finde ich, ist Hertha definitiv ein Aufflugsfavorit und deswegen fand ich die Zielsetzung gut, weil sie Hertha auch mal den Schlendrian austreiben kann, der diesen Verein jetzt halt ein paar Jahren im Würgegriff hält.
Ja, ich bin halt wirklich super gespannt, wo diese Saison hinführt, weil also alle Punkte, die du gesagt hast, total valide, total richtig, aber wir haben eben auch in der Vergangenheit gesehen, ein individuell gut besetzter Kader, bedeutet es halt nicht. Also ich will überhaupt nicht irgendwie den HSV-Witz aufmachen oder so, aber es ist ja eben so. Also Hamburg hatte über weite Strecken immer ein Kader, der durchsetzt war mit hervorragenden Einzelspielern, aber es hat halt hinten raus immer nicht geklappt. Und da ist halt die Frage, ja, Stefan Leithel wurde nach zweieinhalb Jahren gehen lassen, aber es lag eben auch daran, weil er es in zweieinhalb Jahren nicht komplett geschafft hat. Hannover zum Ausstiegskandidat Nummer eins zu führen. Und das ist okay, wenn man einen Dreijahresplan setzt. Wir haben hier schon mal darüber gesprochen, warum der Zeitpunkt auch einfach kritisch war. Aber da ist halt so, Leithel wird das selber im Hinterkopf haben, dass es eben schon mal nicht geklappt hat und dass er da jetzt durchaus wieder unter Druck steht. Und da bin ich auch durchaus gespannt, wie er es am Ende schafft. Ich glaube, das ist definitiv eine Frage. Und natürlich ist es superschwierig nach diesem ersten Spieltag und diesem Spiel im Hinterkopf, da nicht sofort wieder Doomsday auszurufen.
Das ist genau der Punkt.
Ja, aber viel wichtiger ist ja bei solchen Vereinen dann auch immer, wie gehen sie denn mit Ruckschlägen um? Wie performen sie? Und das wird eben natürlich dann, ich würde jetzt mal sagen, so Mitte September wissen wir noch mal ein bisschen mehr.
Weichte Hoffnung habe ich dahingehend. Es gab in der Amtszeit von Stefan Leitel schon mal so einen herben Rückschlag. Das war das Spiel in der Rückrunde gegen Elbersberg, wo man im zweiten Spiel von Stefan Leitel wirklich über den Acker gezogen wurde. Daraus dann aber die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen hat und wenig später 5 zu 1 gegen Braunschalke gewann und dann ja eine wirklich krasse Serie gestartet hat. Also ich traue ihm definitiv zu, die Antworten zu finden. Jetzt gegen Schalke hat man eben, wie gesagt, gesehen, es gibt noch Problemzonen. Linke Schiene ist schwierig besetzt. Du hast aktuell noch einige Verletzte, was die Vorbereitung auch gestört hat. Also Pascal Clemens, John Brooks, Paul Seguin, der Neuzugang, der auch im Mittelfeld eine große Rolle eigentlich spielen soll. Das sind alle Spieler, die aktuell fehlen, was ich irgendwie fast schon… Ich fand es alarmierend, dass Hertha überhaupt nicht spritzig gewirkt hat gegen Schalke. Also du warst läuferisch unter dem Tempo echt unterlegen. Und die 2. Liga funktioniert nun mal sehr über Intensität. Und Schalke wird nicht der letzte Verein sein, der es vor allen Dingen über körperliche Attribute probieren wird, Hertha zu knacken. Und dazu auch manchmal das spielerische Mittel. Also das Übergangsspiel hat aus der 6 heraus nicht so gut funktioniert. Und deswegen hast du Kufnatsky und Reze gefühlt gar nicht gefunden. Reze kam gefühlt und keine Aktion rein. Da braucht es einfach noch mehr abseits des Balles Bewegung. Ja, aber ich finde auf der 6 fehlt irgendwie manchmal so dieser 1,90 Hüne, der da einfach körperlich die Arbeit macht. Denn da steht Diego Demme, der natürlich viel Erfahrung hat und dadurch viel wettmachen kann, aber der 1,70 groß ist, 33 Jahre alt ist, also weder in der Größe noch in der Endgeschwindigkeit vielleicht das Zweitliga-Mittelmaß komplett halten kann oder den Durchschnitt. Das sind so Fragezeichen, die ich habe. Aber jetzt wird es halt super entscheidend, wie du im ersten Heimspiel gegen den KSC dann auftrittst. Da, wenn du da gut spielst, wenn du da gewinnst, dann kann dieses Schalke-Spiel sehr schnell vergessen sein. Aber dieses erste Spiel, das hatte irgendwie sehr viel der letzten Saison. Da gehen bei Hertha Fans und Beobachtern natürlich die Alarmglocken ein bisschen an. Ein bisschen an. Aber ja, vielleicht genug zu Hertha vorerst. Vielleicht kommen wir jetzt zu den anderen Blau-Weißen, wobei es Königsblau-Weiß ist.
Ja, genau. Schalke 04, ich glaube, ich war nicht die einzige Person, die dann durchaus auch ein bisschen überrascht war, wie Schalke in dieses erste Heimspiel. Also man muss dazu immer sagen, Schalke mit diesem Stadion im Hintergrund, im Rücken ist eine Macht, haha.
Das kann eine Wucht entwickeln, das hat härter zu spüren bekommen.
Genau, und also du hast ja auch gesehen, jede gute Situation, sowohl defensiv als auch offensiv, wurde sofort belohnt. Also Schalke-Fans geben durchaus so ein bisschen was an die Hand, um auch zu sagen, sie gehen so ein bisschen in Vorkredit, könnte man ja ehrlich gesagt sagen, um zu sagen, wir stehen erstmal hinter euch.
Die waren mit 80.000 Menschen bei der Saisoneröffnung. Das ist ja völlig irre.
Gut, wir konnten es alle nicht erwarten. Meine Prognose ist tatsächlich auch besser als letzte Saison. Gut, das ist nicht sonderlich schwer und das müssen sie auch. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, Schalke kann sich eine weitere Saison wie die 24, 25 nicht erlauben. Und das aus mehreren Gründen. Und der größte Grund bleibt einfach finanziell. Also es ist rund um diese Genossenschaft enorm still geworden.
Das war ein, ja, Reinfall ist ein großes Wort, aber sie haben definitiv ihre Ziele verfehlt.
Genau, das hatte ich ja auch mal mit Dominik Slisković so ein bisschen angerissen in der letzten Saison. Und ich glaube, durch das wir da nichts mehr gehört haben, können wir auch so ein bisschen sagen, wie das intern auch gesehen wird. Und alleine deshalb musst du besser performen. Ich muss sagen, den Ansatz, den Muslisch jetzt erstmal wählt, der war gut. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie das wirklich über Strecken der Saison gehen können. Ich sehe sie jetzt tatsächlich trotz dieses guten Auftritts nicht als Ausstiegsfavorit. Also, tut mir leid, aber ganz weit weg, weil ich muss halt auch einfach sagen, der Kader ist mir viel zu groß. Also du merkst halt einfach, dass da noch ein paar Spieler stehen, für die sie endlich Abnehmer haben wollen, die sie bis jetzt aber nicht gefunden haben. Und also wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, offiziell laut dran, laut Kicker sind es, glaube ich, 32 Spieler, da kannst du keine Saison gestreiten, ne? Also das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist viel zu viel. Das ist ja ein absolutes Volumen im Budget, was das einnimmt.
Eben. Und da muss ich sagen, also ich glaube, per se tut Schalke gut daran weg von, ja, wir müssen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, an die großen Zeiten erinnern und deshalb müssen wir super schön Fußball spielen. Nein, wir müssen einfach erfolgreich spielen und ihr müsst gut stehen und ihr müsst euch der 2. Liga anpassen. Und ja, es war nur ein Spiel, aber da hatte ich das Gefühl, das hat man zum Teil schon ganz gut umgesetzt, also auf die Identität. Trotzdem muss man sagen, wäre das 1-2, glaube ich, von Hertha früher gefallen. Du hast schon gesehen, nach dem Gegentor, da ging schon so ein paar Alarmanlagen an bei den Schalkerspielern. Aber man muss ja auch sagen, es war auch bis jetzt noch ein Spiel ohne Kinan Karaman. Aber es gibt halt, man muss einfach sagen, Schalke hat eine extrem gute Jugendarbeit und so ein Rem-Wert, der da reingekommen ist, also was, ich verstehe immer noch nicht mehr, dass eine Ding nicht gemacht hat. Aber da sind schon wirklich, also da ist es per se ein guter Mix, aber es kann natürlich auch immer, das war letzte Saison auch schon so, es kann natürlich trotzdem auch richtig, richtig in die Hose gehen, weil die Erwartungshaltung auf Schalke natürlich eine ganz andere ist, als wir sie jetzt haben.
Ich habe eben auch gar nicht erwähnt, also man konnte es vielleicht dem entnehmen, aber natürlich habe ich Hertha auch bei Besser als im Vorjahr, ich glaube die Argumente haben für sich gesprochen, wollte das immer nur noch mal klassifizieren.
Surprise.
Und da habe ich Schalke auch eingeordnet, erstmal mit dem vorigen Argument, schlechter kann es ja auch kaum werden, das habe ich bei einer anderen Mannschaft auch, also so. Und ich muss sagen, ich finde den Kader noch sehr problematisch, wie du sagst, ich finde er ist riesig, er ist schief, er hat viele Spieler, wo man überhaupt nicht weiß, wo die Reise hingeht, da sind auch einige Spieler von Ben Manga geholt worden, die jetzt zurückgekehrt sind von Lein oder so, wo man auch nach wie vor keine Perspektive sieht, also ein Hamasch oder so, ein Bar soll jetzt direkt schon wieder gehen. Du hast eigentlich das Problem, dass du Transferüberschüsse erzielen musst und dafür in Thailand Bulut und Zilla immer noch verkaufen könntest. Frank Baumann war da also so offen, wie ein sportlicher Verantwortlicher nur sein kann im Vorinterview des Spiels und hat sehr klar gemacht, ja, also wir haben schon Druck, die zu verkaufen eigentlich. Aber bislang scheinen da auch nicht die entsprechenden Angebote reinzukommen. Aber dementsprechend kann es natürlich sein, dass die sehr spät im Transferfenster wechseln. Und das ist natürlich immer ein harter Schlag für einen Trainer. Da komme ich auch zum Trainer, der für mich das Hauptargument dafür ist, warum ich sage, dass Schalke besser performen wird dieses Jahr. Und das hat man eben schon gegenhärter gesehen. Ich finde, dass der Miron Muslitsch-Fußball sehr, sehr gut in die 2. Liga passt. Der ist irre intensiv. Das heißt, das kann auch vielleicht irgendwann zu einem Loch kommen. Das würde ich auch sagen. Aber er ist irre intensiv. Er ist mitreißend. Er passt zu dieser Malocha-Erzählung auf Schalke, womit sich Fans identifizieren können. Du hast es angesprochen, Eva. Jeder Zweikampf wird gelobt. Und unter Muslitsch werden viele Zweikämpfe geführt. Also das war irre aggressiv hart gegen Hertha. Die haben gefühlt auch schon sieben gelbe Karten gezogen. Dazu der Platzverweis für Kartic. Also da sieht man, das ist krass. Aber ich finde, er bringt einige Eigenschaften mit, die eben passen. Dieser Kader ist spielerisch nicht gut. Das hast du letztes Jahr gesehen. Da hat Paul Sigow ihn ehrlich gesagt die strategische Gesamtverantwortung gehabt, weil sonst kaum einer fußballerisch was machen wollte, außer Kenan Karaman. Das hat sich jetzt nicht groß geändert. Das heißt, dieser Fußball passt zum Kader. Dieser Fußball, der intensiv ist, passt zu den jungen Spielern. Wir haben Remmert angesprochen, der ein Top-Spiel gegen Hertha gemacht hat. Aber, wen ich auch loben will, Vitaly Becker. Das könnte eine richtige Entdeckung dieser zweiten Saison werden. 20 Jahre alt, eigentlich schon lange ein vielversprechendes Linksverteidiger-Talent, habe oft mit Verletzungen zu kämpfen gehabt. Jetzt einfach sein Profi-Debüt gefeiert gegen Hertha und hat Julian Eitsperger, das andere Talent bei Hertha's Seite, im Zweikampf muss man wirklich sagen, oft abgekocht, hat direkt mit den Fans interagiert, also hat die direkt den Hexenkessel mit angezündet. Also passt vom Typ auch zu Schalke. Und ja, solche Spieler, aber auch ein Philippe Sanche, ein Max Krüger, auch das ist ja ein Teil der Schalke DNA, diese knappen Schmiede auch wirklich mal wieder anzuschmeißen, denn seit Jahren bringen die Talente raus, sie werden aber oft bei anderen Vereinen dann groß und nicht bei Schalke selbst. Auch dazu passt Muzlic und ich finde auch seine Ansprache. Ich finde schon, wenn man auch Videos von ihm sieht und Interviews, der kann Menschen anzünden. Und ich glaube, das ist nach den zwei, ich nenne es jetzt eher blassen Trainern vor ihm, vielleicht auch ein ganz gutes Attribut. Also ich finde, ich weiß nicht, ob, ich kann nicht sagen, ob Muzlic in drei Jahren immer noch funktioniert oder ob sich diese einfache Spielidee und diese Ansprache nicht auch sehr schnell abnutzen kann. Er hat es noch bei Keimfighten über Jahre bewiesen, ist aber noch ein junger Trainer. Aber für den Moment finde ich das sehr gut und auch noch ein Player to Watch, den ich auch erwähnen wollte, Sofiane El-Fawzi hat gegen Hertha top gespielt. Irre gut, kam von Aachen, war der erste Transfer, den man gemacht hat. Und auf der einen Seite ist der läuferisch ein Beast, der war überall und der kann auch richtig kicken. Also ein guter Verbindungsspieler im letzten Drittel. Also das sind so Namen, die kann man sich vielleicht merken und die passen sehr, sehr gut zu Muzlic. Und deswegen wirkt das schon mehr aus einem Guss als im letzten Jahr. Aber ich glaube auch, dadurch, dass ich auch glaube, dass es irgendwann Loch geben kann mit dem Fußball und dass die mit diesem Fußball auch mal auf Granit beißen werden, obere Tabellenhälfte, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Aber das ist dann auch schon Erfolg und viel mehr wird es dann auch nicht.
Genau, wäre natürlich ein wichtiger Grundstein für die Saison schon mal drauf. Wir sprechen immer schon von der Saison drauf, schon mal ist sie.
Naja, aber auch finanziell, du musst halt, du musst ja Spielerwerte schaffen. Das hat Hertha ja auch gut getan. Du bildest junge Spieler aus, wie der Derry Sheeran oder Marzot, verkaufst sie dann für 16 Millionen Euro. Das hat Schalke nicht. Schalke hat in diesem Sommer maximal 1,2 Millionen Euro bislang für Derry Merkin eingenommen. Und so Spieler wie Mehmet Aydin, die aus der Knappenspiele kommen, wechseln dann ablösefrei nach Braunschweig. Und zu dem kommen wir ja noch.
Ja, top Überleitung. Vor allem kommen wir ja zu unserem Spiel 2. Wir können ja schon immer so ein bisschen aus der Giste plaudern. Wir haben eigentlich so gesagt, so zehn Minuten pro Spiel. Aber es ist der Rasenfunk.
Ich glaube aber, wir werden auch noch kürzere Partien haben. Das war jetzt einfach viel.
Es war glaube ich viel. Ihr mögt es uns auch verzeihen, dass bei Partien, wo einer unserer Vereine involviert sind, wir natürlich einfach ein bisschen näher dran sind, auch ein bisschen emotionaler. Und es einfach Vereine gibt, die einfach mehr zu besprechen haben. Besprechenswerte klingen so abwertend. Also mehr zu besprechen haben. Aber wir kommen jetzt zum Samstag. Genau, wir kommen zum Samstag. Und wir kommen zu Elversberg gegen den ersten FC Nürnberg. Elversberg gewinnt das am Ende– ich würde sagen nicht unverdient– gegen Nürnberg durch ein Tor von Maximilian Rohr in der 90. Minute mit 1 zu 0. Ein Elfmeter von Nürnberg wird in der Nachspielzeit noch zum Freistoß korrigiert und kann pariert werden. Absolut kurioses Szenen, wenn ihr da irgendwelche Highlight-Videos von sehen könnt, guckt euch das nochmal an. Es fühlt sich auf jeden Fall zu ganz vielen Fragezeichen bei uns. Ja, das Spiel war über weite Strecken eigentlich ziemlich ausgeglichen, was, man muss ja schon sagen, durchaus auch als Kompliment für die SVE gewertet werden kann. Denn ich kann so viel schon mal sagen, die Hälfte von uns, die hat Elversberg tatsächlich auf einen der Abstiegsränge getippt und damit tatsächlich ja als deutlich schlechter als im Vorjahr nach dieser verlorenen Relegation gegen Heidenheim. Marc, starte doch gerne vielleicht einfach mal direkt mal rein mit deiner Prognose zur SVE.
Absolut, gerne. Ich habe sie tatsächlich auch auf einen Abstiegsrang getippt, so viel kann ich verraten, und dementsprechend auch deutlich schlechter als im Vorjahr. Und dementsprechend war dieses Spiel gegen Nürnberg ein erstes Argument dagegen, denn da wirkten sie insgesamt stabil. Das war ein unspektakulärer Auftritt, aber stabil unter dem neuen Trainer Vincent Wagner. Was für mich schon ein Argument ist, die Trainerposition. Wir haben es alle mitbekommen, logischerweise Horst Steffen, der Macher des Elversberger Erfolgs und Runs der letzten Jahre, ist mittlerweile in Bremen angekommen. Und mit Vincent Wagner haben sie sicherlich ein spannendes Trainertalent dazu gewonnen, der mit Hoffenheim 2 schon das gemacht hat, was Elversberg auch will, junge Spieler fördern, mutigen Fußball spielen, der aber ein Zweitliganeuling ist. Und da ist halt immer die Frage, funktioniert das? Ein anderes Argument für mich ist definitiv die Transferperiode. Du hast mit Mohamed Damar, aber auch Fislik Aslani zwei Unterschiedsspieler oder die wichtigsten Spieler der Vor-Saison verloren, aber auch zwei, nee, drei Namen, die auch genannt werden müssen. Maurice Neubauer, Linksverteidiger, ist zu Hannover gewechselt, Robin Fellhauer in die Bundesliga zu Augsburg und Simi Sahin zum Liga-Konkurrenten aus Kaiserslautern. Das heißt, die ist eine richtige Achse weggebrochen. Und da tue ich mich bislang sehr schwer, die Kreativität dafür zu entwickeln, dass die bisherigen Transfers, die man getätigt hat, ob das ein Luca Pfeiffer ist, der sogar noch verletzt ist, ein Jason Schäker, ein Lukas Poreba, der jetzt vom HSV gekommen ist, oder auch ein Jamra hinten rechts, dass die das in der Form– Ach ja, einen Namen habe ich natürlich vergessen, Elias Baum, der Rechtsverteidiger, zurück nach Frankfurt. Also, dass diese Transfers, die ich eben erwähnt habe, die müssen alle gar nicht verkehrt sein, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das Niveau und das Momentum der letzten Saison halten können. Und dann ist mir der Gesamtkader, wenn er nicht mehr diesen Horst-Steffen-Effekt hat, wenn er vielleicht in eine Negativspirale gerät, wenn nicht mehr die Spieler da sind, die jedes Spiel den Unterschied machen können, dann kann ich mir sehr schnell vorstellen, dass Elversberg in so eine Dynamik kommt, wo man sich schnell hinten drin wiederfindet und keine Antwort mehr findet. Das wäre auch kein Riesendrama für Elversberg, glaube ich. Die sind so aufgestellt, dass die dritte Liga immer noch okay wäre. Aber irgendwie das Gesamtkonstrukt, wie es da steht, überzeugt mich einfach nicht. Da können vielleicht noch eins, zwei Transfers kommen. Aber ich finde nicht, dass ein Bambassee-Conté oder ähnliche Leihspieler dieselbe Qualität haben, wie die Spieler, die letztes Jahr geliehen wurden, von denen man es damals auch nicht gesagt hätte. Aber ich tue mich einfach schwer. Wie ist es denn mit dir?
Ja, ich gehe da komplett mit. Also für mich gelten sie eben auch als Abstiegskandidat. Ich glaube, nicht, weil man eben gesagt hat, ja, nee, das war jetzt irgendwie super überperformt. Also wir haben, glaube ich, lange breit auch diskutiert, was uns an der SVE gefallen hat. Ich glaube, mein Problem liegt genau, wo du es auch beschrieben hast. Also der Kader, der hat einfach einen brutalen Adanus gehabt. Und klar, du hast mit Vincent Wagner interessanterweise genau den Trainer von der Mannschaft geholt, wo du so viele Leihspieler von hattest.
Vielleicht nicht ganz zufällig.
Nicht ganz zufällig, aber ich muss auch einfach sagen, also ich finde es erstmal super interessant, Vincent Wagner und Muslice sind ja zwei von acht Trainern insgesamt, die überhaupt gewechselt sind. Und du hast eine ganze Reihe von Trainern, die wirklich komplettes Neuland haben. Sowohl bei den Aufsteigern eben als auch bei den restlichen Vereinen in dieser Liga. Und für Vincent Wagner, er ist jetzt mit der TSG Hoffenheim 2 in die dritte Liga aufgestiegen und wechselt dann eben zur zweiten Liga. Das ist halt einfach ein brutaler Sprung, das muss man so sagen. Und er arbeitet jetzt aber halt eben nicht nur mit jungen Spielern, die eben sich wie ein Schaufenster spielen wollen, sondern du hast eben die Transfers aufgezählt. Da sind eben auch Namen dabei, die durchaus Zweitligarerfahrung haben und deshalb auch so gewisse Erwartungen mit sich bringen. Und ich sehe da auch einfach, ich sehe ehrlich…
Frustpotenzial oder?
Ja, ich glaube Frustpotenzial, aber auch einfach, ich sehe da nicht, dass Horst Steffens Fußball, also diese Fußballidee so nachhaltig drin ist oder bzw. auch vielleicht gar nicht sein soll unter einem neuen Trainer, aber dass man das jetzt weiterspielen kann. Und ja, also es war ein ausgeglichenes Spiel gegen Nürnberg. Also sie haben sich da nicht schlecht verkauft. Aber mir hat halt auch wirklich dieser… Ja, mir haben einfach diese spielerischen Elemente, ehrlich gesagt, überstritten.
Ja, das gewisse Etwas, was man letztes Mal hatte.
Die haben mir gefehlt und ich glaube, das ist eben auch der Grund. Also es kann trotzdem reichen. Ich habe sie jetzt nach unten getippt. Du hast, wir werden da bestimmt noch sprechen, also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Vereinen, wo wir sagen, boah, für die können es richtig, richtig schwierig werden, wenn sie sich nicht besser anstellen als im letzten Jahr. Aber ich sehe da einfach zu viele Fragezeichen hinaus.
Und dann sind wir vielleicht auch bei Nürnberg. Die haben dieses Spiel verloren. Und wenn wir schon sagen, Elbersberg jetzt nicht dolle gespielt, aber trotzdem irgendwie der verdiente Sieger, sagt das vielleicht auch ein bisschen was über den FCN aus. Denn das war jetzt echt noch kein guter Auftritt. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Ich kann vorweg sagen, ich habe Nürnberg in etwa gleich gut eingeschätzt.
Same.
Same, sehr gut. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass das, finde ich, eine ganz schöne Black Box ist. Also du hast schon wichtige Spieler verloren. Ziemers ist jetzt final zu Brighton gewechselt. Jens Kastrup hat den Verein verlassen. Emre Lih ist gegangen, der ja auch nicht schlecht gescord hat letzte Saison. Also ein paar Spieler sind eben gegangen. Und ich finde, du hast wieder eine natürlich hochspannende Transferphase bislang, was die Neuzugangsseite angeht. Aber da sind auch wieder sehr viele Experimente dabei. Entweder weil die Spieler super jung sind. Also wir reden beispielsweise über den Artem Stepanov, der ukrainische Haaland, wie er jetzt schon getauft wird. Der bewegt sich sogar gleich auf dem Feld. Das ist irre. Gruselig. Das ist wirklich ein bisschen gruselig. Oder Spieler wie ein Luchoschvili, der noch nie 2. Liga gespielt hat, aber schon ein bisschen erfahren ist, aber die 2. Liga eben nicht kennt. Oder ein Diron vorne im Sturm. Das ist eine sehr datengetriebene, aber auch wilde Gesamtkonstellation dieser Kader, dass das natürlich auch eine Unwucht entwickeln kann. Ich glaube, es hängt extrem davon ab, wie zentrale Bausteine wie Robin Knoche und Julian Justwahn funktionieren werden. An denen wirst du ablesen können, ob diese Saison jetzt eine gute wird oder eine schlechte. Denn du hast es in diesem ersten Spiel gesehen, es ist schön, dass so viele junge Spieler zum Einsatz kommen. Aber dadurch wirkt man vielleicht auch manchmal ein bisschen grün hinter den Ohren. Man schafft das nicht über Ansätze hinaus. Klose hat auch das Abwehrverhalten teilweise kritisiert, dass das auch sehr unentschlossen war. Wenn er sagt, ein Ball musst du auch mal auf die Baustelle in Elbersberg kicken. Das Element fehlt dann abseits von Robin Knoche vielleicht manchmal auch. Der Kader steht ja auch noch nicht, man will da noch was machen. Das spricht aber auch für eine späte Transferphase insgesamt. Ich habe da einfach das Gefühl, das könnte richtig lange dauern, dass wir dazu sortieren. Am Ende sehe ich Nürnberg eher im Mittelfelder Liga. Das wäre okay mit so vielen jungen Spielern, aber ich sehe gar nicht, dass sie jetzt um die ersten sechs Plätze mitspielen. Das ist mir dafür viel zu wild und unerfahren im Kader.
Ja, da gehe ich tatsächlich komplett mit. Es war ja letzte Saison Platz 10. Das ist halt absolut das. Wenn es eine Niemandsland der Zweitligatabelle gibt, dann ist es Platz 10, gefühlt wirklich. Ich muss sagen, ich habe Nürnberg in Teilen im Testspiel gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Da war vor allem so ein langes Testspiel geduldens. Da muss ich sagen, sie sind halt überhaupt nicht reingekommen. Wenn du dir wirklich Sachen in der Zweitliga nicht erlaubst, also auch generell im Fußball, aber vor allem gefühlt immer in der Zweitliga nicht erlauben kannst, dann ist das so eine erste Hälfte zu verschlafen oder einfach nicht drin zu sein. Und ich erwarte da ehrlich gesagt doch ein bisschen mehr vom FCN. Also ich finde halt einfach in dieser Konstellation, die wir in der Zweitliga haben, mit keinen klaren wirklich Favoriten. Also natürlich hast du mit Hertha und Düsseldorf zwei, glaube ich zwei Vereine, die wirklich aktiv den Ausstieg mehr oder weniger als Ziel ausgerufen haben. Aber du hast halt nicht so die ganz großen Namen streng genommen. Also wie es in den letzten Jahren so war. Und eigentlich wäre per se mein Gedanke, wenn du irgendwann in die Bundesliga-Aufstiegung steigen willst, wäre das per se jetzt eine gute Saison, dafür zumindest mal den Grundstein zu legen. Und dafür ist mir der Kader auch zu schief. Also keine Ahnung, eventuell soll offensiv ja noch Marius Vuel von Hannover kommen. Darauf aber irgendwie alles zu setzen, den für zwei, drei Millionen zu holen, der auch keinerlei Zweitliga-Erfahrung hat, der im Pokalspiel zwar gezeigt hat, was er kann. Das ist mir zu viel Risiko. Und da würde ich mit, also mit allem, was du gesagt hast, mitgehen, Marc. Da fehlt mir eine Menge und ich sehe ja auch nicht, wie sie, also wie gesagt, ich habe auch ungefähr gleich bis vielleicht leicht besser, aber leicht besser heißt in dem Fall wirklich gefühlt so anderthalb Plätze weiter nach oben, weil ich es auch einfach nicht sehe.
Das ist eben wie gesagt sehr viel Kristallkugel bei so einem jungen Kader dabei. Und wie gesagt, so Spieler wie Caspar Janda können den Verein vielleicht sogar noch verlassen. Also da ist noch richtig viel Unruhe, glaube ich, im Kader. Und es bleibt dabei, ich kann immer noch nicht einschätzen, wie gut Miroslav Klose als Trainer ist.
Ja, das wird eine super interessante Saison dafür.
Ich glaube auch, ja.
Eben weil wir ja so viele Neulinger auch in dieser Liga haben.
Definitiv.
Und das wird das auch nochmal richtig zeigen.
Dann haben wir das doch. Dann lass mich doch gerne mit dem nächsten Spiel weitermachen. Das heißt, Paderborn gegen Kiel. Paderborn setzt sich am Ende 2 zu 1 gegen Kiel durch. Ist da lange nach einem Unentschieden aus in dieser Partie, die recht ausgeglichen war für Paderborn, was das erste Spiel unter Trainer Ralf Kettemann, auch ein Liganeuling, vorher U19 des KSC trainiert. Und für Kiel war es die Rückkehr nach einem Jahr erster Liga. Beide Teams wussten also nicht ganz genau, wo sie stehen. Hoffmeier bringt Paderborn in Führung. Kiel gleicht erst in der 82. Minute durch einen sehr sehenswerten, direkten Freistoß von Gigovic aus. Dabei sollte es aber nicht bleiben, denn Bilbija macht in der 19. Minute der Nachspielzeit auch da viel Drama. Den Lucky Punch und das 2 zu 1 für Paderborn, ein Sieg, der insgesamt, finde ich, in Ordnung ging, weil Paderborn die leicht überlegene Mannschaft war. Und Kiel sich spielerisch schon noch ziemlich schwer tut. Wo hast du Kiel, wenn wir bei denen vielleicht beginnen, denn einsortiert bei dir?
Also ich kann direkt mal vorwegschieben, so als kleinen Hot Take. Für mich geht tatsächlich keiner der beiden Absteiger wieder hoch.
Guck mal, da stehst du im starken Kontrast zu mir. Aber das kann man alles verargumentieren in dieser Liga.
Ich muss dazu sagen, und ich bin damit vor allem bei Kiel auch nicht die Einzige. Also nur vier bei uns aus den Zwölf haben Kiel als direkten Aussteiger getippt. Ich sehe da halt, also du hast eben das spielerische angesprochen, und ich sehe da halt vor allem in der Offensive Probleme. Also Maschino war eben doch durchaus absehbar, dass er geht. Remberg und Pichler sind drei Spieler, die aus der Offensive gegangen sind. Gut, Pichler war viel verletzt, vielleicht nicht so der Impact-Spieler. Aber also sie haben ja durchaus was auf dem Transfermarkt gemacht, aber ich sehe da tatsächlich, ja also ich habe da viele Bauchschmerzen. Ich halte Marcel Rapp weiterhin für einen guten Trainer. Ich bin auch froh irgendwie, dass sie mit ihm weitergemacht haben, aber ich sehe da trotzdem Probleme, und die hast du eben in diesem Paderborn-Spiel gesehen, und dazu muss man ja auch einfach sagen, einfach darüber spreche ich mir gleich noch mal, aber heads up auch an Paderborn, es ist wirklich immer mit was für einer, sie sind glaube ich gefühlt bei niemanden da oben drin, aber also ich greife schon vorweg, wie gesagt also zu Kiel. Ich glaube sie haben durchaus Aktien im Ausstieg, also hier können wir ja nicht dieses Besser gleich schlechter machen, sind halt Absteiger. Ich glaube sie haben durchaus Aktien im Ausstieg, sie werden da immer wieder mitmischen, aber sie gehen halt für mich nicht hoch. Dafür fehlt mir da zuviel und dafür muss ich einfach sagen, ja hat mir glaube ich selbst im Ausstiegsjahr noch Sachen gefehlt und da haben sie es ja geschafft, aber ja ich sehe es nicht. Wie siehst du es?
Ich sehe es tatsächlich. Also erstmal die Trainerposition, das hast du gesagt, ich halte viel von Marcel Rapp, ich finde es schön mit welcher Ruhe das im Abstiegsjahr verhandelt wurde und dass er dann verlängert hat, das finde ich spricht erstmal für den Verein, für eine gewisse Stabilität, für eine gemeinsame Idee. Ja, mit Schuhdumaschine hast du natürlich den besten Stimmer der letzten Saison verloren, aber hast natürlich auch 8 Millionen Euro bekommen, wovon ich glaube, dass auch noch was reinvestiert werden könnte bzw. soll. Also dementsprechend könnte es da ja vielleicht auch einen Ersatz geben. Ich finde aber auch Phil Harris nicht ganz verkehrt, muss ich sagen. Ich finde, sie haben einen sehr spannenden Kader, wo sie ja auch viele Spieler, die zur Achse gehören, ja auch durchaus halten konnten oder durch ebenso erfahrene Spiele ersetzen konnten. Also Stefan Schwab, der mit 34 Jahren noch mal aus Griechenland jetzt zu Kiel gekommen ist und dieser neue Louis Holtby sein soll. Ich halte viel…
Noch ein witziger Kommentar einfach.
Ja, wirklich schon, ne? Vor ein paar Jahren hätte man das nicht geglaubt. Alexander Bernazon kann echter Unterschiedsspieler in dieser Liga sein. Steven Skripski, finde ich, funktioniert auf Zweiligerniveau immer noch wunderbar, ist der neue Kapitän. Ich finde, Robert Wagner ist ein Superspieler eigentlich, der von Freiburg geliehen wurde. Gjigovic hat jetzt mit dem direkten Freistoß wieder bewiesen, dass er eine individuelle Klasse hat, die man in der 2. Liga auch nicht so oft sieht. Ja, ich glaube, da sortiert sich noch ein bisschen was im Kader. Das ist so. Und ich sage auch nicht, dass Kiel hier irgendwie davonreitet, um Gottes willen. Aber ich glaube, sie werden bis zum Ende der Saison in Wörtchen im Aufstiegskampf mitreden. Dafür war das Spiel natürlich noch kein gutes Beispiel. Ich glaube aber, das liegt eben auch daran, dass sich dieser Kader auch gerade noch sortiert. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie offensiv noch mal einen Unterschiedspieler dazuholen und dass dann irgendwann dieses ja auch durchaus komplexe System was Marcel Rapp hat. Denn das ist ja sehr flexibel, viele Positionsrochaden und so. Das hat sie ja stark gemacht in diesem Aufstiegsjahr, wo jeder Spieler irgendwie wichtig war. Das könnte irgendwann greifen und dann könnten sie ins Rollen kommen und sehr schwer zu schlagen sein. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass sie oben mitspielen werden. Genau. Und zu Pada Born. Ich habe sie als in etwa gleich gut eingeschätzt. Beziehungsweise, Moment, nee, ich lüge glaube ich gerade. Nee, ich habe sie als schlechter. Genau. Ich wollte mich gerade, musste mich gerade selber verbessern. Denn da bin ich wiederum der Meinung, boah, Ralf Kettemann, 38 Jahre alt, vorher die U19 des KSC trainiert. Das ist schon richtig grün hinter den Ohren. Ich weiß, es gibt genug Beispiele in den letzten Jahren, die bewiesen haben, dass das kein Ausschusskriterium für Erfolg sein muss. Aber ich finde, es ist noch schwierig, zusammen in der Kombination damit, dass du mit Aaron Zehntner und Anza zwei immens wichtige Spieler verloren hast und sie durch Spieler ersetzt hast, die alle super jung sind und super zweitligar unerfahren. Also ob das ein Lucas Coppado ist, ein Bennett Bröger, Marco Werner, das sind alles komplette Neulinge. Dennis Simon ist ein 19-jähriger Keeper, der es jetzt gegen Kiel auch schon solide gemacht hat, aber der vielleicht auch mal seine Fehler drin haben wird. Das ist dann normal. Und auch da kann man von Lucas Krasniak halten, was man will, aber dass der diese Mannschaft hat überperformen lassen, ich glaube, das steht außer Frage. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das Ralf Kettemann in seinem ersten Jahr gleich gelingen wird und dass der Kader insgesamt etwas schlechter geworden ist als im Vorjahr. Und dementsprechend schätze ich sie als leicht schlechter ein. Ich sage nicht, dass Paderborn gegen den Abstieg spielt oder völlig einbricht, das glaube ich einfach nicht. Das hat auch dieses Kiel-Spiel jetzt gezeigt. Die sind stabil, die sind weiter eklig zu bespielen. Und wenn da am Ende Platz 9 bei rumkommt, dann glaube ich, beschwert sich keiner in Paderborn. Und ich glaube, in genau die Richtung könnte es diese Saison gehen.
Ich finde es sehr interessant, dass wir in manchen Punkten komplett auseinandergehen, aber in solchen Tagen einfach auf einer Wellenlinie sind. Ich bin tatsächlich entspannt. Also man muss dazu ja sagen, nicht nur mal Paderborn den Trainer verloren, sondern ja eben auch mal wieder den Sportdirektor. Und da ist eben auch ja vom SC Veyral jemand gekommen, der per se eigentlich in dieses Paderborner-Gefüge ganz gut reinpasst. Man muss ja eigentlich immer sagen dafür, dass Paderborn gerade auf der Sportdirektor-Position so viel Fluktuation hat, weil sie eben immer jemanden hatten, der brutal gute Arbeit geleistet hat. Das spricht ja auch für sie. Ich bin halt tatsächlich gespannt. Du hast gesagt, es gab schmerzhafte Abgänge, ein paar Neuzugänge, aber es ist am Ende des Tages immer noch ein Lucas-Quassin-York-Kader in großen Teilen. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie sehr das vielleicht irgendwann zu Problemen führen könnte. Du hast gute Einzelspieler, das können wir, glaube ich, nicht bestreiten. Da bin ich mal tatsächlich sehr gespannt, wie das auch sein wird. Kommst du dann nicht als neuer Trainer und als neuer Sportdirektor hin und dann sagst du, ne, wir machen jetzt mal hier Tabula Rasa und holen mal komplett einen neuen Kader. Aber da bin ich tatsächlich auch gespannt. Ich glaube, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, ist Paderborn auch bei keinem von uns in den Ausstiegsplätzen gelandet. Was ich sehr interessant finde, weil es zum einen immer für Paderborn spricht, weil sie eigentlich immer unter dem Radar fliegen, egal, wie gut die Vorsaison war. Und andererseits glaube ich, ja, dieses Jahr, sie können immer, glaube ich, da oben mal so ein bisschen reinrutschen. Aber es fehlte, man muss ja auch sagen, in den letzten Jahren dann auch immer hinten raus die nötige Konsequenz. Und ich glaube auch einfach, dass man es im ersten Jahr unter Ralf Kettemann auch diese nötige Konsequenz nicht finden wird. Von daher kurz und schmerzlos. Bei mir reicht es nicht für den ganz großen Ausstiegskampf, daher auch leicht schlechter. Was aber, muss man ja trotzdem einfach sagen, führen den SDPaderBahn unter neuem Trainer, unter neuem Sportdirektor absolut in Ordnung ist.
Absolut. Und jetzt haben wir den KSC schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Genau. Karlsruhe gegen Preußen Münster war ein durchaus flottes Spiel am frühen Samstag Nachmittag. Karlsruhe kann spät Preußen Münster mit 3 zu 2 besiegen. KSC war dabei 30 Minuten in Überzahl nach Coulis roter Karte. Münster allerdings mit einem richtig starken Comeback, nachdem der KSC schon 2-0 geführt hatte. Und in Unterzahl noch das 2-2 gemacht. Am Ende kann aber ausgerechnet, könnte man sagen, Lilian Eklov als ehemaliger VfB Stuttgart-Spieler als Match-Winner hier hervorgehen. Ja, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, wo man da anfangen kann. Ich würde aber tatsächlich mal sagen, lass uns doch mal beim Team anfangen, das letzte Saison dann doch durchaus etwas überraschend den Klassen ja halt doch noch geschafft hat. Marc, was ist denn deine Einschätzung zu Preußen Münster?
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin da positiver gestimmt als viele andere. Also ich habe sie als klar besser eingeschätzt. Ja, das liegt daran, dass ich sehr viel von der Transferperiode halte und auch vom Trainer. Ja, Alexander Ende hat bei Färlen einen mutigen Fußball spielen lassen, aber der war ja in der dritten Liga auch sehr erfolgreich, muss man sagen. So und ich finde, dass ein Hans Steffen beispielsweise bewiesen hat, dass du mit so einem mutigen, sehr riskanten Fußball musst du in der Zeitenliga nicht auf die Schnauze fallen. Also und ich finde, dass die Transferperiode sehr, sehr spannend ist. Die haben auf der einen Seite viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung dazu gewonnen. Marvin Schulz beispielsweise von Kiel, Paul Jäckl, der aus Braunschweig die Zeitliga kennt, bei Union gespielt hat. Marco Meyerhöfer von Fürth bekommen. Aber auch interessante Talente, also Oskar Wilhelmsson, der schwedische Stürmer, der bei Darmstadt gespielt hat. Wenn der explodiert, ich finde den körperlich gut, und Batista Maier, der ein Unterschiedsspieler in der 2. Liga sein kann, finde ich. Bei Ulm hat der super gespielt in dem halben Jahr, was er da war. 24 Jahre auch, er ist alt. Dazu jetzt auch noch Antonio Tikvic, 21-jähriger Invertieger aus der Bayern-Akademie, so weit ich weiß, der zuletzt bei Watford war. Das, finde ich, ist erstmal eine sehr spannende Mischung. Es sind auch zwei Spieler von Färl quasi mitgekommen mit Ende. Das heißt, er hat auch ein, zwei Vertraute, die den Fußball kennen. Lokoc, der jetzt getroffen hat gegen Karlsruhe, ist einer dieser beiden Spieler. Und das ist erstmal eine Mischung, die ich interessant finde. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass die so ein leichtes einfach Momentum entwickeln könnten, weil jetzt ja auch, man hat es ja letztes Mal gesehen, Sascha Hildmann war lange da und das hat abgerieben. Und irgendwann waren wir an dem Punkt, wo man gesagt hat, das geht nicht mehr, wir brauchen einen neuen Impuls. Und der neue Impuls war ein sehr ungewöhnlicher mit den Namen, die dann auf der Trainerbank saßen aus. Zum Beispiel Christian Panda. Und selbst der hat aber gereicht, um diese Mannschaften ein Stück weit explodieren zu lassen in den letzten Spielen. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einen ähnlichen, nicht so starken natürlich, aber einen ähnlichen Effekt in dieser Saison geben könnte. Und ich finde auch, dass das Spiel gegen KSC bewiesen hat, dass diese Mannschaft versucht, diesen Umspielansatz auch schon umzusetzen. Sie hatten teilweise 70 Prozent bei Besitz beim KSC. Das ist schon krass. Ich weiß, bei Besitz allein reicht nicht, aber zumindest spricht man da fußballerisch vielleicht schon einigermaßen eine Sprache. Und deswegen, auch da, ich sage nicht, die wählen das neue Elberswerk und spielen plötzlich um Platz 3 mit, um Gottes willen. Aber ich glaube, sie könnten deutlich früher nichts mehr mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben. Und das wäre für Münster mehr als nur ein Erfolg.
Ja, finde ich super interessant. Also, das ist so, ich verstehe total, was du sagst, aber vielleicht liegt es daran, dass sich dann Alex Ennis Ferl dann durchaus ein bisschen enger verfolgt habe, durch die 3. Liga. Und für mich waren da halt, also sie haben eine solide Saison gespielt, aber eine so Saison mit für mich persönlich zu vielen, ja, Auf- und Abschwankungen, genau. Und das ist in der 3. Liga noch mal ein bisschen was anderes, wo du dann mit anderen Qualitäten da irgendwie auch ganz gut die Klasse halten kannst. Da sehe ich halt in der 2. Liga durchaus Schwierigkeiten, weil es war kein schlechtes Spiel gegen den KSC. Aber man muss ja auch sagen, wie du dich in der Anfangsphase präsentiert hast, war nicht gut. Das war defensiv. Da waren viel zu viele Lücken. Und natürlich in Unterzeit dann noch ein 2-2 rauszuholen. Absolut ehrenzwert. Ich will das auch gar nicht runterreden. Aber da hatte ich halt dann auch das Gefühl, da kommen sie halt mehr übers Kämpferische und dieses Jetzt-erst-Recht, als dass da für mich persönlich, von dem, was ich gesehen habe, so eine ganz klare Spielidee zu sehen war. Und das ist halt mein Problem hinten raus. Also Alex Endes ist sehr gewohnt gewesen mit Ferl, halt immer diese Underdog-Rolle auszuspielen. Weil man wusste so immer so, Ferl gibt halt größere Vereine in Ostwestfalen, die halt da immer so die Nase vorhaben. Und da können sie dann halt immer so ein bisschen ärgern, indem sie da eben auch gut reinspielen. Aber ich sehe da eben auch einige Probleme. Und ja, der Kader ist besser. Das hast du gesagt. Du hast das gesagt. Da gehe ich komplett mit. Aber auch da, was ich auch schon an einer Stelle gesagt habe, es birgt nämlich auch da dann durchaus Risiken, weil du eben dann auch eine andere Erwartungshaltung hast. Natürlich erwartet niemand von Preußen Münster, dass sie jetzt in jedem Spiel 80 Prozent Ballbesitz haben und die Mannschaft kontrollieren. Aber wenn du dir halt die Erfahrung einkaufst, erwartest du halt auch so eine gewisse Anpassung an die Liga. Und ich sehe da einfach durchaus Probleme. Ich möchte an der Stelle aber natürlich auch sagen, freuen mir jetzt fühlende Leute, die in die Kommentare schreiben, natürlich, wenn ich sie als Absteigertüppe, ich kann da durchaus am Ende, dass alles meine Schwarz-Weiß-Blau-Preußen nicht vollständig ablegen und gebe auch durchaus zu. Es führt mir auch nicht weh. Und ich freue mich jetzt auf die Spiele gegen Preußen. Man muss ja auch sagen, für sie wäre es natürlich auch einfach eine schöne Geschichte, wenn sie dann langsam aber sicher im umgebauten Stadion in dieser 2. Es ist natürlich schöner, so ein Stadion in der 2. Liga zu füllen als in der 3. Liga. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns auch alle einig. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie es schaffen werden im verflicksten 2. Jahr.
Und dann sind wir beim KSC. Ich habe das Wort heute schon mal benutzt, aber hier möchte ich es unterstreichen. Black Box. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht so richtig, was ich vom KSC zu erwarten habe. Ich habe sie jetzt in etwa gleich gut eingeschätzt. Das liegt auch an einer bislang nicht so sonderlich spektakulären Transferphase. Sie haben Max Weiß verloren als Jungkeeper, der zu Burnley gewechselt ist, aber dementsprechend auch gutes Geld eingebracht hat. Die anderen Abgänge sind noch nicht so schwerwiegend, wie ich finde. Leon Jensen war am ehesten das, was man Stammspieler bezeichnen würde. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist Roko Simic ein Experiment, glaube ich. Andreas Müller, Bernhardt– mal gucken, wie der Max Weiß ersetzen wird. Bernhardt!
Tut mir leid, ich muss den Uli Hoeneß-Witz machen an der Stelle. Wir müssen manchmal auch ein bisschen prollig hierherkommen. Irgendwo weint Uli Hoeneß.
Er zitiert gerade schon wieder das Grundgesetz. Dieses erste Spiel hat aber auch gezeigt, warum sie in etwa gleich gut sein werden, weil ich finde, Christian Eichner ist nach wie vor einer der besten Trainer dieser Liga, der einfach das Maximum aus einer Mannschaft herausholt, Jahr für Jahr, der eine gute Spieleidee hat. Die fallen einfach nicht unter ein gewisses Grundniveau unter Eichner. Ich habe gewisse Bauchschmerzen mit dem Kader, muss ich auch sagen, weil gewisse Spieler echt nicht jünger werden. Sebastian Jung ist in dem Fall auch einfach namentlich ein lustiges Beispiel. Aber sie haben immer noch Marvin Vanizek, der mit 32 Jahren immer noch am Rollen ist, wie die jungen Leute sagen. Und sie haben einen neuen Unterschiedspieler, Louis-Ben Fahad. Ich hatte das im Hertha-Base-Podcast. Übrigens könnt ihr da auch sehr gerne reinhören, wenn euch mehr Sachen zu Hertha interessieren, haha. Aber ich habe es da schon gesagt, das ist mein Player to watch diese Saison. Ich halte super viel von Louis-Ben Fahad und der hat Louis... Das ist auch geil, Louis-Ben Fahad. Naja, hoffentlich schleicht sich das jetzt nicht ein. Aber der hat ja jetzt schon mit Tor und Vorlage direkt auch mal einen Unterschied gemacht. So, super interessanter Spieler, 19 Jahre alt, aus der eigenen Jugend, so eine hängende Spitze. Das heißt auf der einen Seite Torriecher, auf der anderen Seite spielerische Qualitäten. Der und Wanicek könnten allein dafür sorgen, dass man insgesamt einfach nicht unter so einen Mittelfeldplatz rutscht. Aber ich glaube auch, mehr wird es nicht. Denn dieser Kader ist superdünn. Und wenn einer dieser Spieler ausfällt, hast du ein extremes Problem. Also dieser Kader finde ich ist unausgewogen. Er bräuchte noch Spieler im besten Fußballeralter, die, glaube ich, einfach so einen guten Mittelbau im Kader bilden. Weil junge Spieler hast du durchaus. Auch einen Rafael Pinto Pedrosa auf der rechten Abwehrseite. Aber insgesamt ist der Kader für mich zu dünn, um irgendwie oben in Wort mitzureden. Und deswegen glaube ich, könnte das eine Mittelfeld-Saison werden. Und dann frage ich mich sehr, was mit Christian Eichner passiert. Weil lange macht er das so nicht mehr mit. Das ist meine These.
Ja, finde ich super interessant. Ich habe sie tatsächlich nicht nur als besser im Vorjahr gewertet, sondern ich kann es ja auch hier schon mal droppen als Aufstiegskandidat.
Wo kommt das her, Eva? Erklär mir das.
Ich weiß es. Also ganz ehrlich, für mich ist es halt so ein bisschen der Grund, was du schon ein bisschen aufgezählt hast. Insgesamt diese Stabilität auf der Trainerposition, aber auch eben in weiten Teilen des Kaders. Das kann in beides Richtungen führen. Auch das hast du schon gut dargelegt. Gerade ein Thema knapp besetzt. Also du hast nur auf dem Papier zwei Mittelstürmer und dann eben mit Verhard die hängende Spitze. Also da ist durchaus auch irgendwie so ein bisschen das Fragezeichen hinter. Aber also ich bin halt wirklich mal gespannt. Weil Karlsruhe, bei mir das Problem in den letzten Jahren war auch immer, dass sie es nicht geschafft haben, über wirklich 34 Spieltage hinweg eine konstante Saison zu spielen. Konstant im Sinne, wenn sie es wirklich mal schaffen, an guten Leistungen festzuhalten, dann können sie halt eigentlich immer eine Gefahr nach oben werden. Das haben sie nicht geschafft und da bin ich mal gespannt, ob sie so ein bisschen dieses ganze acht neue Trainer in der Liga, beziehungsweise acht Trainerwechsel, insgesamt dann ja viel mehr neue Trainer in der Liga, ob sie das alles so ein bisschen für sich nutzen können. Das war so mein Hintergedanke, ich sage aber auch direkt, es war auch ein bisschen nicht mangels Alternativen, das wäre ein bisschen gelogen. Aber ich kann mir einfach vorstellen, dass sie so ein bisschen die Rolle spielen könnten, die irgendwann Heidenheim oder so gespielt hat oder auch irgendwie Bochum führt. Einfach diese Nutzen, dass sie halt diese Stabilität und Kontinuität mitbringen und das eben dann ausschlaggebend sein könnte. Aber wie gesagt, ich gehe auch voll mit mit deinen Punkten. Ich verstehe, es ist immer schön, ich verstehe immer beides. Das ist ja das Schöne am Fußball, dass man das immer ganz gut nachvollziehen kann eigentlich.
In Christian Alchner we trust, in the Carter we maybe trust. Altes Sprichwort von mir. So, kommen wir zum nächsten Spiel, würde ich sagen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Sehr schön. Dann gehen wir über zu einem Spiel, wo auch fünf Tore gefallen sind. Bloß noch mal ein bisschen deutlicher auf der Teilhalle, denn Darmstadt gewinnt 4 zu 1 gegen Bochum. Ja, willkommen zurück in der Liga, lieber VfL. Würde ich sagen, zum Auftrag direkt mal eine Packung in Darmstadt bekommen. Die Lilien, muss man sagen, waren von Beginn an die bessere Mannschaft, sind früh in Führung gegangen. Lidberg, wer auch sonst, muss man mittlerweile bei Darmstadt sagen. Und denen ranken sich ja übrigens ganz viele Transferegerüchte. In Ägypten soll man an ihm interessiert sein, da das ja ein wilder Wechsel. Aber das nur am Rande. Bochum hat auf der anderen Seite aber auch brauchbare Gelegenheiten gleich in der 34. Minute durch Brošinský aus. Vor dem Pausenpfiff erzielt wieder Lidberg das 2 zu 1. Und dann geht es in der Zeiten- und Halbzeit auch noch ein bisschen dahin. Denn nach nur zwei Minuten erzielt dann Lidberg das nächste Tor, sein Dreierpack und Vukotic. Zehn Minuten später dann per Ecke das 4 zu 1. Jeweils sieht die Bochumer Abwehr wirklich nicht gut aus. Ja, für Bochum's Offensive ein okayes Spiel. Die haben alles gegeben, hatten brauchbare Chancen für die Defensive, aber definitiv ein blamabler Auftritt. Ein klarer Auftakt siegt für Darmstadt und viel Arbeit, glaube ich, für Bochums Trainer Dieter Hecking.
Ja, gehe ich komplett mit und ich muss einfach sagen, ja, nicht, dass ich das Ergebnis erwartet hatte, aber ja, der Kader birgt halt eben in der Defensive für mich ja ganz große Probleme, weil ich habe halt nicht das Gefühl, dass die Probleme, die in der ersten Liga existiert haben, nur mit Kevin Vogt hier oben werden können. Also du hast mit Bernardo Oehmer und Oddez III in Verteidiger verloren. Vogt sollte eben diese große Stabilisierung, weiß ich nicht, Ruhrpol sein, aber damit behäbst du halt keine Defensivprobleme auf lange Zeit mit einem einzelnen Spieler. Und ich sehe bei Bochum einfach, ich weiß es nicht, ich sehe da einfach auch immer noch Probleme mit Hacking als Trainer. Ich weiß, dass super viele von ihm überzeugt sind und sagen, in der 2. Liga läuft es anders, aber man muss auch einfach sagen, er kommt ja nicht frisch rein als Trainer in der 2. Liga, sondern er ist mit dieser Bochumer Mannschaft abgestiegen und am Ende auch vollkommen verdient abgestiegen.
Aber hast du nicht das Gefühl, dass man das sehr von seiner Person trennen kann, weil es davor eigentlich schon in die Binsen gegangen ist und eher so ein Himmelsfahrtskommando angetreten ist?
Ja, aber ich hatte halt immer das Gefühl, dass es auch immer wieder Diskussionen gab, ob man mit ihm jetzt wirklich weitermacht oder nicht. Und ich habe manchmal so quer gelesen auf Blue Sky oder so, was die Bochum-Fans da sagen. Und da sind einfach viele Leute mit den taktischen Entscheidungen, die er in einem Spiel fällt, also beziehungsweise davor und auch im Spiel, einfach nicht zufrieden. Und man muss einfach sagen, also Darmstadt ist unter Kohfeldt für mich– wir haben es jetzt so oft schon gehört– hat auch irgendwie immer eine Black Box. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich von denen in so einer Saison… Du kannst alles bekommen von denen. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, ja, es ist auch einfach brutal, als Absteiger nach Darmstadt zu reisen am ersten Spieltag. Also in der zweiten Liga gibt es keine einfachen Gegner. Aber es gibt sicherlich auch angenehmere Punkte in die Saison zu starten. Aber ich sehe sie einfach nicht als Aussteiger. Ich glaube einfach, sie haben halt die meiste Bundesliga-Erfahrung von allen Mannschaften in der zweiten Liga. Das ist einfach so aus den letzten fünf Jahren. Und daran werden sie halt auch gemessen werden. Und dafür sehe ich da einfach im Kader viel zu viele Probleme.
Also ich bin, also auch da wieder sehr legitimer Standpunkt und kann definitiv so kommen. Ich habe sie tatsächlich auf meinen Platz 3 getippt. Aber auch in dem Sinne mit Bauchschmerzen, weil ich mich bei diesem letzten Aufstiegsplatz so ehrisch schwergetan habe. Das hättest du würfeln können bei so drei, vier Kandidaten. Mein ausschlaggebender Punkt war, ich finde schon, wenn der Kader einigermaßen so jetzt bis zum Ende der Transferperiode zusammenbleiben sollte und dann auch gewisse Spieler fit werden, Gerrit Holtmann, Unjeka, Quateng, Erhan Masovic, super wichtig für die Abwehr. Wenn diese Spieler dann fit werden und reinkommen, dann finde ich, ist das schon ein Kader, der besser ist als viele in der zweiten Liga. Ich finde, dass du, also bei Broschinski ist die große Frage, ob er bleibt. Wenn er bleibt, kann er ein wirklich guter Stürmer in der zweiten Liga sein. Zusammen auch im Doppelpass dann mit Philipp Hofmann, der diese Liga in- und auswendig kennt. Sie haben im Mittelfeld interessante Jungs, auch in KAW beispielsweise ausgeliehen. Francis Onjeka ist an sich jemand, der hochtalentiert ist. Und ich finde, dass du auch auf der Außenverteidiger-Position Spieler hast, die in der ersten Liga vielleicht nicht sonderlich gut waren, die in der zweiten Liga aber richtig gut sein können. Ich finde, Maximilian Wittek kann einer der besten Linksverteidiger dieser Liga sein, mit seinem Offensiv-Rang, mit seiner Flankenqualität. Kann sein. Das ist aber natürlich viel konjunktiv, das sehe ich schon. Auch, wie gesagt, ist die Frage, bleibt Matthias Speerow, bleibt Ibrahima Sissoko, das sind natürlich noch so Fragezeichen dieser Kader.
Ibrahima Sissoko und Ibrahim Sissoko, nicht zu verwechseln, die beiden.
Ja, der eine hat ein I und der andere hat ein I. Punkt, das ist völlig wild, was da auf dem Trikot passiert ist. Aber lassen wir das an der Stelle. Also, du hast viel auch Potenzial, was sich in der Saison entwickeln kann. Leandro Morgalla beispielsweise, auch ein junger, talentierter Innenverteidiger. Ich finde erst mal die Mischung des Kaders gut. Und ich glaube, dass Dieter Hecking relativ schnell Ruhe in den Kader bekommen könnte. Und auch das ist in einer zweiten Liga sehr wichtig. Denn irgendwann fängst du dann an, konstant zu punkten und vielleicht mal den einen Punkt mitzunehmen, den dein Konkurrent nicht mitnimmt. Und ich glaube, dahingehend könnte Dieter Hecking ein guter Trainer sein. Aber du hast es angesprochen, es sind auch viele Spieler gegangen. Es gibt Fragezeichen im Kader, das sehe ich alles. Ich sehe nur das Potenzial dafür, dass sich ein paar Fragezeichen auch in Ausrufezeichen entwickeln könnten. Und dann hat Bochum einen wirklich stabilen Kader für diese Liga.
Ja, ich glaube, mein Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass ich, also Großteil des Kaders ist halt immer noch da geblieben. Und das kann halt auch richtig in die falsche Richtung gehen. Weil, again, das sind Spieler, die haben alle in den letzten Jahren auch viel Bundesliga gespielt. Und sowas kann auch immer dazu führen, dass dann Spieler denken, naja, aber also ich könnte jetzt, also ja, nicht Bundesliga-Spieler. So und ich habe es schon bei Vereinen gesehen, die eben abgestiegen sind. Und das kann immer, das kann wirklich immer in beide Richtungen führen. Entweder sind die sagen, okay, wir wollen da wieder hin mit genau diesem Verein. Oder sie sagen halt, gut, ich spiele jetzt eine halbe Saison so, dass mich dann halt in der Winterpause ein Bundesligist wiederholt. Weil sie sehen, ich bin halt einer der besseren Spieler aus diesem Zweite-Liga-Kader. Und das ist halt für mich die große Krux, ob das passieren wird bei Bochum. Und das ist eben auch die große Gefahr. Und die sehe ich halt nicht eins zu eins so bei Kiel, weil sie eben nur ein Jahr Bundesliga gespielt haben und eben generell einen anderen Kaderaufbau hatten. Und das ist, glaube ich, meine Bauchschmerzen damit, wo ich einfach denke, das kann halt auch richtig schief laufen. Und du kannst eben auch in die Fußstapfen von– ist zu beleid– aber Hertha, Schalke, HSV und Co. treten und da eben dann den Wiederaufstieg nicht schaffen.
Die Gefahr besteht definitiv. Aber dann kommen wir vielleicht zu dem anderen Team, Darmstadt. Das habe ich als in etwa gleich gut eingeschätzt. Aber auch da das KSC-Argument und das jetzt schon oft genutzte Wort Black Box. Das hast du auch schon gesagt. Mein erster Vergleich nach diesem 4 zu 1 war– ja, das würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn sie im nächsten Spiel– das ist dann übrigens gegen Nürnberg– 4 zu 1 verlieren. Absolut möglich! Das ist wirklich krass. Das hat man ja auch letzte Saison gesehen. Das ist so ein– dieses Krofeld Darmstadt ist so hot and cold, das entweder rasiert das drei Spiele durch oder verliert vier und sieht aus wie ein Aufsteiger. Das ist wirklich krass. Also, der Kader ist aktuell individuell gut besetzt. Sollte Liedberg bleiben, hast du einen der besten Stürmer dieser Liga. Das ist ein Faustpfand. Und sie haben jetzt mit Marco Richter– also, Marco Richter, finde ich, hat in diesem ersten Spiel bewiesen, dass er in Normalform und wenn er sich wohlfühlt, ein richtig guter Spieler ist für die zweite Liga.
Aber Marco Richter ist für mich Darmstadt als Spieler, weil auch Marco Richter ist eine absolute Blackbox.
Ich kenne das ja von Hertha, genau. Also, mal hat er aus 40 Metern das Ding in Winkel gejagt oder er war nicht existent. Das ist so. Und so war es ja beim HSV stückweit auch bei seiner Leie. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ihm Kohfeldt jetzt im ersten Spiel echt viele Freiheiten gelassen hat. Und das tut Marco Richter gut. Und der hatte da ein, zwei Szenen, also wie er quasi das, ich glaube, zweite Tor einleitet. Da lässt er einen Spieler von Bochum super aussteigen und spielt eine perfekte Flanke auf vorn, wie der den Ball in den Pfosten köpft und dann macht den Dietberg rein. Mega-Szene. Und ich glaube, dass solche Momente könnten den Unterschied machen. Sie haben keine Stamm-Spieler verloren, keine wichtigen Spieler verloren, haben mit Patrick Pfeiffer einen guten Inverteiger gewonnen, haben in Japan zweimal zugeschlagen. Das hatte sich in den letzten Jahren oft ausgezahlt für deutsche Vereine, wie ich finde, auch wenn ich diese Spieler erst mal per se nicht einschätzen kann. Der Kader ist sehr stabil in seiner Grundform. Da bleiben die Clemens Riedels dieser Welt immer noch. Marcel Schuhn ist da immer noch. Fabian Holland ist jetzt sogar zurückgekehrt und kann für ein Jahr noch ein bisschen Stabilität bringen. Ich denke auf keinen Fall, dass die im Aufstiegsrennen wirklich ein Wort mitreden werden. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie mal den kleinen C reinhalten. Aber am Ende eher etwas um Rang 7 erreichen. Auch das finde ich ist für eine Darmstädter Saison mehr als in Ordnung. Dementsprechend sind sie aber, wie ich finde, dementsprechend relativ gleich gut. Vielleicht sogar leicht besser. Das könnte man mir jetzt auch vorhalten, dass ich das eigentlich auch anmoderiert habe. Aber ich würde sie rundum als in etwa gleich gut einschätzen.
Darf ich eine Sache zu Patrick Pfeiffer loswerden? Der ist ja durchaus Ex-Darmstädter. Der hat ja schon einige Jahre bei Darmstadt 98 gespielt.
Das ist richtig.
Ist dann zu Saison 23, 24 zum FC Augsburg gewechselt. Wurde in der Saison 24, 25, wenn ich das richtig sehe, zu Young Boys Bern verliehen. Dann zurück zum FC Augsburg. Wurde dann aber nach Magdeburg verliehen. Und ist jetzt bei Darmstadt. Er muss einfach wieder nach Hause kommen, der Junge. Sehr, sehr witzig, muss ich sagen. Aber von daher, das ist eine sehr gute Rückkommunikation. Aber bei mir ist halt einfach, ich glaube, bei mir ist einfach Kohfeldt das Problem, dass ich einfach nicht weiß, ja, welchen Kohfeldt kriegen wir denn jetzt mal über die Saison? Der, der Darmstadt übernommen hat und absoluten Running gelegt hat oder die Rückrunde unter Kohfeldt.
Die war gruselig.
Die war halt einfach nix. Also, das muss man einfach so ganz deutlich, die war einfach nix. Du hast, du hast es eben schon angesprochen, du hast in der Liedberg generell super interessanter Sturm, Liedberg, Hornby, Corridor und dann noch Bialek vorne drin von Wolfsburg gekommen. Aber ja, also es kann halt auch, ich glaube, meine Prognose zur Darmstadt, die Spiele werden uns, glaube ich, werden immer unterhaltsam sein.
Das ist ja auch ein Gewinn.
Wertfrei, das kann in beide Richtungen gehen für Darmstadt. Aber deshalb habe ich sie nämlich auch gleich bis vielleicht leicht besser als im Vorjahr. Wenn du da halt mal Konstanz rein kriegst, gibt es sicherlich auch mal das Potenzial, auch weiter oben anzuklopfen. Aber ja, Florian Kohfeldt bleibt für mich, weiß ich nicht, der könnte das Ehrenmitglied von den drei Fragezeichen werden. Aber auch nur, weil er ein ganz großes Fragezeichen für mich ist.
So, stark.
Justus, Peter, Bob und Florian.
Sehr schön. Mal gucken, für welche Abteilung er zuständig wäre. Aber dann kommen wir doch, wenn wir über Spektakel und Unterhaltung reden, müssen wir jetzt auch zur Aminia kommen. Erzähl doch mal, Eva, was ist denn da passiert?
Du, ich weiß es auch nicht und an der Stelle auch. Bitte entschuldigt meine Stimme. Ich habe sie gestern Abend im Stadion gelassen. Auch der Sprechmuskel ist ja durchaus ein Muskel, den man trainieren muss, wenn man so zwei Monate lang nicht trainiert hat. Weil, Surprise, sonst schrei ich nicht so viel in meiner Freizeit. Manchmal ist es dann doch durchaus etwas komisch. Aber ne, also Bielefeld kann das erste Spiel nach dem Ausstieg mit 5 zu 1 gegen von Thuner Düsseldorf gewinnen. Düsseldorf geht in der ersten Hälfte durchaus verdient in Führung. Nach einer gelb-roten Karte gegen Tim Oberdorf kann Bielefeld aber das Spiel schon in der ersten Halbzeit noch ausgleichen und dann in Halbzeit 2 komplett drehen und zu ihren Gunsten gestalten und 4 Tore schießen. Ja, und hinterher gab es auch noch 10 Minuten Nachspielzeit, wo ich glaube, Halbdeutschland sich immer noch fragt, wofür. Also bei allem Respekt für Verletzungspausen, VR-Checks und Co., das war doch ein bisschen lang. Ja, ich weiß nicht, Marc, vielleicht möchtest du einfach mal mit Düsseldorf tatsächlich reinstarten.
Kann ich damit tun.
Ich glaube, per se gibt es da einige Parallelen, die wir auch schon zu härter gesagt haben.
Ja, doch, durchaus. Also Düsseldorf schätze ich als in etwa gleich gut ein. Und das ist bei einer Mannschaft, die ja wirklich ein gehöriges Wort auch im Aufstiegskampf letztes Jahr geführt hat, ja erstmal was Gutes. Das liegt natürlich zum einen an Trainer Daniel Thun. Der ist jetzt wirklich schon lange da, seit 2022, würde man behaupten, nach Eichner wahrscheinlich der Dienstälteste in dieser Liga. Du weißt, was du mit ihm bekommst. Der Kader hat sich schon verändert, muss man sagen. Du hast auch mit dem Johanneson einen wirklich wichtigen Spieler verloren, aber auch interessante Spieler dazugewonnen. Das muss man auch sagen. Interessante Transferphase. Und wie ich finde, ein Spieler dazugewonnen, der jetzt auch gegen Bielefeld getroffen hat, Cedric Itten. Ich musste an einer anderen Podcaststelle mal nennen, wen ich als Torstützenkönig tippen würde. Und ich habe Cedric Itten gesagt, ich finde, der passt als Stürmertyp so krass in diese Liga. Und ich glaube, bei Düsseldorf wird sich sehr viel auf die Stürmertore konzentrieren. Und dann ist Cedric Itten dein Mann. Ansonsten ist das erstmal per se wirklich ein stabiler Kader mit vielen Unterschiedsspielern. Ich finde, dass Christian Rasmussen jetzt auch, trotz des Ergebnisses gegen Bielefeld, schon gezeigt hat, ja, mit dem wird zu rechnen sein, sowohl im Tempo als auch in der Technik. Also wie der einmal da Handwerker davon gelaufen ist, der sah doppelt so schnell aus, was ist da passiert? Egal. Vieles. Vieles ist passiert. Handwerker ist nicht passiert in dem Moment. Nee, aber du hast natürlich immer noch so Spieler wie Matthias Zimmermann, wie Florian Kastenmaier, die einfach diese Liga kennen, die ein Grundniveau haben. Dazu, wie gesagt, junge Spieler, die vielleicht explodieren können. Das ist in den letzten Jahren bei Düsseldorf eigentlich auch verlässlich passiert, wenn wir an Solis und Co. denken. Und deswegen wird Düsseldorf definitiv wieder eine Rolle im Aufschließkampf spielen. Und daran ändert, finde ich, auch dieses Spielnix, denn das hat seine ganz eigene Geschichte geschrieben, mit eigenartigen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen, mit Pech bei Gegentoren. Ich finde, du kannst an diesem Spiel überhaupt nicht ablesen, wie es um Düsseldorf bestellt ist und um Gottes Willen schon gar nicht, dass sie jetzt irgendwie einbrechen werden in der Saison. Ich würde das krass einklammern, dieses Spiel.
Ja, ich gehe da auf jeden Fall eigentlich komplett mit, was du gesagt hast. Also, es hat Rick Itten natürlich never forget, als Itten und Itter bei der Spielvereinigung viertgespielt haben.
Itten auf den Tisch.
Es war eine gute Zeit. Nein, also generell erwarte ich auch von Düsseldorf viel. Ich sehe sie auch da oben mit drin. Letzte Saison hat einfach hinten raus nicht gereicht, unter anderem eben auch. Und das ist mein Problem. Ich finde, sie haben immer wieder so Spiele, wo die Abwehr einfach nicht passt, wo sie individuelle Fehler hinten drin haben, wo die Zuordnungen nicht passen. Und da bleibe ich auch bei, dass das so eine Mini-Problem-Spendenstelle werden könnte. Nicht explizit am Spiel gestern gesehen, sondern einfach weil– also ich finde die Offensive gut besetzt, aber defensiv habe ich schon manchmal das Gefühl, dass es da nicht immer perfekt läuft. Du hast natürlich eine absolute Konstante mit Florian Kastenmaier da hinten drin. Da weißt du einfach, was du bekommst. Aber ich sehe da trotzdem– also ich sage dazu, sie sind für mich Ausstiegskandidat, nicht unter den ersten zwei. Sie müssen gegebenenfalls ihre Trauma noch mal überwinden in der Relegation. Wenigstens diesmal nicht gegen Bochum, könnte man eventuell sagen, das steht schon mal fest. Ja, aber per se bin ich halt auch fern davon, dass man einen Tun festgehalten hat. Ich mag das in diesem– kurz ein bisschen pathetisch– aber in diesem Fußballbusiness, wenn man eben so eine gewisse Konstanz hat und da eben auch weiter reingeht. Aber ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich finde, man hat gestern zum Teil nach Abpfiff, zumindest von Spielerseite, mir ein bisschen zu viele Ausreden gegeben. Tune hat das an der Pressekonferenz ganz anders gemacht. Übrigens sehr, also sehr gute Aussagen von ihm. Den merkt man einfach.
Generell, Daniel Tune, PKS sind eine Sonne.
Super.
Super sympathischer Kerl, super klarer Blick. Mega.
Ja, also, ja, ich finde halt, ich muss halt einfach sagen, man kann den Unterzahl verlieren, aber man muss überlegen, ob man den Unterzahl so verliert. Und man muss dazu sagen, wir haben schon über ein Spiel gesprochen, wo sich der die Mannschaft den Überzahl schwer getan hat. Wir sprechen gleich noch über ein anderes Spiel, wo schwer getan ein anderes Feedment ist. Aber ja, also da muss ich sagen, ja, du kannst dieses Spiel verlieren und sicherlich kann man auch alles diskutieren. Ich finde halt einfach ganz kurz dann nur meine Einschätzung zu, die gelb rote Karte von Timo Oberdorf, in jedem anderen Spiel würde ich sie nicht pfeifen. In dem Spiel, das was Patrick Alta über weite Strecken gefiffen hat, muss er sie fast geben, weil er hat halt ab der zweiten Minute Geld für jedes taktische Foul gegeben.
Das ist der erste Fehler, aber dann musst du eine Linie haben.
Und er hat ja am Ende, könnte man sogar sagen, hätte er, glaube ich, Jermin Siebert auch noch vom Platz stellen können und Co. Also er ist an der Linie einfach nicht treu geblieben. Und von daher verstehe ich auch den Unmut vieler Düsseldorf-Fans, versteht mich da nicht falsch. Aber ja, da muss man am Ende auch sagen, dafür, dass Timo Oberdorf durchaus noch ein paar Erfahrungen, also kein junger Spieler ist, der das erste Mal in der 2. Liga spielt, sondern das kennt, der Kapitän der Mannschaft ist, da erwarte ich von ihm tatsächlich auch in dem Moment einfach ein bisschen mehr Fingerspitzengefühl für die Situation, weil er weiß, wie es aussehen kann. Der Linien-Richtschuh steht direkt davor, der Schiedsrichter steht zwei Meter entfernt, dann bleibt er einfach weg und es passiert halt nichts. So in der gegnerischen Hälfte, glaube ich sogar. Also muss man an der Stelle selber wissen. Ja.
Und dann kommen wir zu Aminia. Ich fange da vielleicht mal an mit dem Blick von außen.
Gerne.
Das Ergebnis bestätigt ja einige, die sagen Aminia, Durchmarsch. Also Aminia entwickelt sich ja ein bisschen zum Belgien von WMs und WMs. So sehr Geheimfavorit, dass es schon gar kein Geheimfavorit mehr ist. Denn auch ich würde sagen, also ich gehe nicht so weit wie andere, die sagen, die spielen um den Aufstieg mit oder wären Top 6. Um Gottes willen, das glaube ich wirklich nicht. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass Aminia eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen wird. Und das wäre als Aufsteiger doch überragend.
Es wäre so schön.
Es wäre so schön. Es wäre so schön. Das liegt daran natürlich, wie sie sich zum einen in der Liga, aber auch im Pokal logischerweise letztes Jahr präsentiert haben. Da zeigt sich eine Mannschaft, die eine spielerische Identität hat, die richtig Herz hat, die eine tolle Achse hat an Führungsspielern, die sich nicht verstecken in Druckphasen. Ich finde das krass. Ich finde, dass mit Kniat sehr gut passt. Wir wissen auch alle, die Kniat rausrufe. Da hat sich ein bisschen was getan in Wielefeld. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, dass diesen Verein gerade einen Duft des Positiven umweht. Und ich glaube, der verweht nicht so schnell in dieser Saison. Ich glaube, der wird sie ein Stück weit tragen. Und wird sie in jedem Spiel mindestens mal auf Augenhöhe spielen lassen. Klar, es werden ja noch Auftritte da sein, wo sie Lehrgeld zahlen werden. Es ist ja in Teilen auch ein junger Kader. Aber insgesamt ist das alles irrestabil. Und ich halte sie auch für eine Mannschaft, die absolut einen Tabellen-Mittelfeldplatz belegen können. Vielleicht sogar überraschend auf so was wie einen neuen Land, der in Köln drin. Aber viel höher, glaube ich, wird es dann nicht. Und dieses erste Spiel hat eben bewiesen, dass sie mithalten können. Wie gesagt, es war ein Freakspiel. Das wird jetzt nicht jedes Mal so laufen.
Klar, ja.
Aber auch die Transfers, spannend. Also, dass man dann Marvin Mehlum bekommen hat, das ist krass für einen Aufsteiger. Man hat einige junge Spieler dazu gewonnen. Klar, Louis Oppi zu verlieren, Marius Wöll zu verlieren. Aber immerhin darf er jetzt U23 bei Hannover spielen.
Ja, Star-Cos-Mann.
Aber ich würde auch behaupten, es wird jetzt nicht mehr spät zu krassen Abgängen kommen. Oder gibt es da Gerüchte, küchemäßig irgendwas, dass man sagt, nee, der Russo oder so, da könnte noch mal jemand zuschlagen. Wenn das nicht passiert, dann halte ich diese Mannschaft für absolut kassenhaltsfähig. Nicht nur das, sondern sie werden in meiner Welt auf einem Mittelfeldplatz landen und eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen.
Nee, also du hast sehr viel Richtiges gesagt. Also generell muss ich einfach sagen, dass das Wort Konstanz und Stabilität zu hören bei Minja Bielefeld tut mir sehr gut und ey, Freunde, ihr könnt euch endlich drauf freuen. Ich darf endlich legal über Bielefeld in diesem Podcast reden. Die habe ich sehr zurückgehalten bisher. Das muss man auch einfach sagen in dieser Folge. Das ist so. Nein, ich muss einfach sagen, ich habe tatsächlich bei Mitch Kniart schon lange gesagt, ich glaube, dass der, also er ist ja auch einer dieser Neulinge, also sowohl Mitch Kniart hat keinerlei Zweitliga-Erfahrung und bis auf Noah Sarin, Basé, Tim Hanferka und Mavi Melem hat auch niemand in diesem Kader Zweitliga-Erfahrung.
Kudofsky hat eine Hinrunde bei Münster gespielt, aber das kann man kaum zählen.
Niemand hat mehr, also andersrum formuliert, mehr als 30 Spieler haben nur drei Spieler in diesem Kader. Und das ist natürlich auch ein absolutes Risiko. Da ist einem bewusst, aber man muss einfach sagen, zum Beispiel Tim Hanfaker hat bei der Verpflichtung gesagt, er hat das Gefühl, er kommt in ein absolut funktionierendes Gefüge. Und das war für ihn hintenrum auch ein Ausschlag geben, was natürlich auch total für Michael Mutzen und mit Kniat spricht, was sie da geformt haben. Und das ist eben, bis auf Luis Oppi, gut Marius Wöhrl, eine Story ein bisschen kompliziert haben mit dieser Kaufoption, Rückkaufoption und jetzt dieses Hickhack, wo Hannover erst drei Millionen wollte und jetzt heißt es mehr. Und zweifel kann er doch für eine Million gehen. Mal schauen, was da jetzt noch kommt. Aber prinzipiell muss ich sagen, spricht halt dafür, dass auch Jonas Kerske den Vertrag verlängert hat und Stefano Russo hat seinen Vertrag verlängert. Also das sind, wenn auch alle Spiele, die kosten dann jetzt auch ein bisschen Kohle. Und ich meine, man muss einfach sagen, für Luis Oppi hinten raus, irgendwie die drei Millionen zu holen, das ist halt, also das muss auch Bielefelds Weg sein. Da bin ich der festen Überzeugung, Jugendspieler zu entwickeln. Du hast mit Daniel Richter einen aus der U19, der einfach unfassbar viel Potenzial zeigt. Da bin ich richtig gespannt. Und du hast jetzt eben auch, dass es wird vielleicht ganz interessant werden, weil du eben jetzt neu zu dieser Saison in der Oberliga Westfalen U23 oder in der zweiten Mannschaft wieder an Start bringen konntest. Das könnte auch durchaus ein Weg sein, um einigen Spielern trotzdem Spielzeit zu geben. Die U23 wird von dem ehemaligen Co-Trainer, also einem der Co-Trainer, mit Knien hat trainiert. Einer Draht, also. Genau. Und eben auch eine vielleicht, natürlich nicht einzig gleiche Spielidee, aber einfach die wissen, wie der andere funktioniert. Das könnte alles ein Vorteil sein. Ich muss einfach sagen, ich war komplett überrascht von diesem Spiel, weil man muss einfach sagen, es war eben auch in der Vorbereitung Co, es war kein Offensivfeuerwerk. Man hat im letzten Testspiel gegen Monaco, okay, es ist Monaco, aber gegen Monaco gesehen, da war, ja, Chancenverwertung war es nicht so, um jetzt halt fünf Tore zu erzielen. Also man muss diese Tore sich auch erstmal rausspielen. Mit Julian Kania hast du einen, der weiß ich nicht, der meistens immer noch als Stoker fungiert, was ich auch okay finde, das sehen auch andere anders. Aber der halt da ist und der kann, wir haben endlich einen Spieler, der Elfmeterschießen kann. Leute, die uns in der ersten Drittliga-Saison gesehen haben, wissen, ich glaube, da haben wir 75 Prozent der Elfmeter verschossen. Von daher, das sind alles so Punkte, und man muss einfach sagen, du hast mit Mael Corbos, einem Kapitän, der einen richtig schwierigen Start hatte, sich aber reingefunden hat ins Team und für mich gestern ein Spiel gemacht hat, also dem konntest du zwischendurch nicht ansehen, dass der noch nicht eine Minute 2. Liga gespielt hat. Und das fand ich schon sehr eindrücklich. Natürlich, es wird nicht immer so laufen. Das weiß, ich würde sagen, 95 Prozent in Bielefeld wissen das, aber es ist halt trotzdem eine Euphorie, gerade hinter diesem Verein, also für mich als Fan noch nie so existiert hast. Du hast 17.000 verkaufte Dauerkarten, du hast 27.000 Mitglieder, du bist innerhalb von– also es ist eine Mitgliederkampagne letzte Saison gestartet, zum 120-jährigen Jubiläum. Da stand man, glaube ich, bei 15.000 und wollte 19.005 erreichen zum Jubiläum. Wir sind bei 27.000 Mitgliedern in einem Jahr. Natürlich viel mit Pokal zu tun. Viele werden nach diesem Jahrablauf auch wieder aus ihrer Mitgliedschaft rausgehen. Ist okay, die wollten dann die Vorteile auch mitnehmen, die sie biegen, aber das spricht sehr viel für den Verein. Ich hoffe nur einfach, man bewährt Ruhe. Das ist mein letzter Satz dazu. Ich hoffe, man bewährt Ruhe. Ich freue mich auch, wenn es im Stadion ab und zu mal ein bisschen leerer wird. Das ist schon sehr anstrengend und auch sehr gruselig zum Teil. Aber per se, ich bin großer Fan von Mitch Kniart. Ich finde, er spielt Fußball, auf den wir uns, glaube ich, in der 2. Liga durchaus freuen können. Also auch in der Allgemeinheit, weil er durchaus gerade gegen den Ball sehr ansehnlichen Fußball spielen lässt.
Kniart nieder, Diaminja ist da. Ich muss sie machen.
Eva, komm. Ist okay.
Du wolltest eine Folge mit mir, du bekommst eine Folge mit mir.
Na ja, ist okay.
So, gehen wir weiter und gehen wir zu den Sonntagspartien. Und da hat Hannover 96 1 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen. Das war in meinen Augen von Beginn an eine spielerisch klare Angelegenheit. Auch wenn Hannover zunächst die Effektivität, ruhig, fehlte, waren sie fußballerisch dennoch deutlich besser als Kaiserslautern. 96 kontrollierte die Begegnung. Der FCK wollte eigentlich nur kontern und konnte sich bei Kieper Krall bedanken, dass die Begegnung nicht schon viel früher entschieden war. Hannover behielt die Ruhe, blieb am Drücker und erzielte dann in der 74. Minute in Person von Joker, Asseco und Kili. Übrigens, Hertha Eingewächs. Da rede ich mal kurz über Hertha, den verdienten Siegstreffer.
Herz bricht.
Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen so. Einer der vielen Jungs von Hertha, die halt früh vom FC Bayern weggekauft wurden tatsächlich und dann weitergegangen sind. Hannover zeigt also schon früh, dass sie auf Kurs sind und Casas-Lautern muss, wie ich finde, spielerisch dringend noch einen Gang zulegen. Eva, wie hast du denn 96 eingeschätzt? Da sind ja einige richtig im Hype. Ich war noch ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Ja, ich glaube, für mich war es einfach vor diesem Spiel– wir haben mal wieder das schöne Wort– Black Box. Ich muss dazu sagen, der Umbruch bei Hannover 96 war groß, neuer Trainer, zu 95 Prozent neuer Kader gefühlt. Und das kann natürlich immer in beide Richtungen gehen. Du kriegst so schnell hin, Automatismen reinzufügen, du kriegst so schnell hin, den Kader eben so zu formen, dass du Fußball auf hohem Niveau spielen kannst. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, wenn dieses erste Spiel indikativ sein könnte, dann hat das mit diesen Automatismen und der T-Shirt brutal gut funktioniert. Also ich glaube, das kann man schon relativ klar so sagen. Da hat sehr, sehr viel gepasst, da ist sehr, sehr viel zusammengelaufen. Du hast natürlich im Tor, glaube ich, die Neuerung, ehrlich gesagt, dass du da jetzt Neul drin hast, Thieler, der zum 1. FC Köln gewechselt ist. Von daher natürlich war ein Risiko für mich, da sind sie tatsächlich– für mich waren sie einfach Top-Aufstiegskandidat, weil ich einfach sagen muss, dieser Umbruch hat Sinn. Also weil ein Ding, was mir an Hannover letztes Jahr nicht gefallen hat, war einfach der Kader. Der hat nicht gestimmt, der hat nicht gepasst, der war für mich zu viel Rumgewürfle, was man ja vielleicht noch so nehmen könnte.
Ich fand den ja auch wirklich bieder.
Ja, genau. Also du hattest halt so das Gefühl, da hat man halt irgendwie nichts gegen Andreas Vogelsammer, aber einen Spieler geholt, der war mit Bielefeld gut. Entschuldigung. Aber hat dann halt bei Union und dann in England gespielt. Und ich glaube, der ist jetzt in der dritten Liga auch einiges besser einfach aufgehoben, um da halt eben nochmal seine Körperlichkeit auszuspielen. Und der hat nicht in diesen Anofer-Kader reingepasst. Dann hast du irgendwie Nilsen. Nilsen ist ein Spieler, den werde ich bis in alle Ewigkeit nicht verstehen. Vollständig Anofer 96. Das ist für mich auch eine Wundertüte. Aber generell muss man einfach sagen, mit Jakota, mit Bundu, mit Taibii. Das sind drei super interessante Spieler. Und man muss einfach sagen, es war ein bisschen unfair, als wir heute irgendwie von der Bank bringen konnten. Ja, im Prinzip auch den Sieg eingewechselt. Der Kader könnte beides ein Vorteil, die Kader breiter als auch ein absoluter Nachteil sein, weil er ist für mich noch zu groß.
Da haben auch einige Spieler jetzt in der U23 gespielt, ein Rogo und so weiter, die auch neu sind.
Man muss halt einfach sagen, wir fangen jetzt nicht die Diskussion an. Aber es ist natürlich ein absoluter Vorteil. Hannover 2 spielt jetzt nicht mehr die 2. Liga, sondern die 3. Liga, sondern die Regionalliga. Es ist natürlich ein Vorteil, die Spieler dahin zu schicken, die jetzt letzte, sondern die 3. Liga gespielt haben, jetzt Regionalliga, kann man nutzen für so eine Zwecke. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was wir dann noch von Hannover 96 sehen. Aber was sagst du denn?
Ich kann den Hype um Hannover definitiv verstehen. Bei mir war das Ding– also, wenn ich Christian Titz fände, offensichtlich muss man fast sein. Toller Fußball, mutiger Fußball, moderner Fußball, Fußball, der immer Spaß macht, toll, aber auch ein Fußball, der komplex ist. Und wo die Frage eben bestand, oder immer noch besteht, und das kann man nach einem Spiel eben nicht genau sagen, funktioniert das auf Anhieb. Eher beteuert, die Spieler sind insgesamt so früh gekommen, dass man schon sehr früh Automatismen trainieren konnte. Und wie gesagt, das Lagerland-Spiel ist ein Indikator für, trotzdem möchte ich das erst mal über ein paar Wochen sehen. Die Transfers auch natürlich super spannend. Das steht völlig außer Frage, aber wenn man sich die Transfers anguckt, davon hat gefühlt noch nie jemand 2. Bundesliga gespielt. Also da fällt ein Pichler raus, da fällt ein Neubauer raus, aber du hast so Namen wie Gita, Taibbi, Sterner, der es bei Kiel noch nicht gespielt hat, Kälmann, Bundu, Okon, Matsuda. Also Spieler, die nicht nur nicht die 2. Liga kennen, sondern Deutschland nicht kennen. Also das ist teilweise aus Japan, Südafrika, Polen, Frankreich zusammengeholt. Und das kann funktionieren, aber ist natürlich erst mal sehr wild. Das sind sehr unterschiedliche Typen, Kulturen, die da zusammenkommen. Und das kann auch kompliziert sein. Und dann können sich das Spieler vielleicht nicht wohlfühlen und Ähnliches. Also das birgt viele Fragezeichen. Und auch dahingehend wollte ich mich nicht festlegen, dass das auf Anhieb funktioniert. Und das dritte Argument ist, wer dann ja auch gegangen ist. Du hast Trisoldi verloren, du hast Zieler verloren, du hast Neumann verloren und Halstenberg. Das war eine zentrale Achse der letzten Saison. Ja, einer nicht sonderlich erfolgreichen Saison, aber trotzdem Spieler, die eher positiv hervorgestochen sind. Also es lag ja jetzt nicht an Halstenberg oder Trisoldi, das letztes Jahr nicht gelaufen ist. Und da seine komplette Führungsaktie zu verlieren und die vielleicht beste Innenverteidigung der Liga mit Halstenberg und Neumann, das fand ich, ich fand, das war nicht selbstredend, dass das jetzt besser funktionieren wird. Und wie gesagt, ein Spiel, das schon stabil aussah, die haben noch keine Bäume ausgerissen, aber es sieht stabil aus. Das kann Spaß machen und das kann auch dazu führen, dass Hannover am Ende aufsteigt. Das Potenzial sehe ich definitiv. Es würde mich aber auch nicht wundern, wenn da oft noch ein bisschen Sand im Getriebe ist, Spieler Formlöcher haben, erst mal ankommen müssen und am Ende wird Hannover 5. Aber mit der ganz klaren Perspektive, dass das dann im Jahr darauf klappt. Hannover ist spätestens in zwei Jahren der klare Aufstiegsfavorit. Das sehe ich. Dieses Jahr bin ich einfach noch ein bisschen, aufgrund der Faktoren, die ich genannt habe, ein bisschen gehemmter und deswegen sage ich, in etwa gleich gut. Aber wie gesagt, ich sehe total, dass das auch explodieren kann.
Mein größtes Fragezeichen ist, ob man die Chancen ein bisschen besser nutzt oder sich ein bisschen besser noch in Position führt. Torchancen. Also das war so der Knipser fehlt. Ja klar.
Also Kelmann hat es in Polen einigermaßen bewiesen, Pichla in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig, finde ich, dass er der Knipser ist. Ja und was ein bisschen doof war, nach meinen Tipps und so, haben sie dann auch noch das Yoko Taro geholt, der letztes Jahr so krass war bei Casas Lautern. Und da dachte ich, na toll, also weil der ist für sich genommen schon ein Faktor, warum es noch mal besser laufen könnte. Ja, dementsprechend, das ist schon alles sehr gut. Und mal gucken, ob es jetzt in einem Jahr schon so weit ist oder eher in zwei Jahren. Und dann sind wir bei Casas Lautern. Boah, also, boah, also, ich kann ja, soll ich mal vorweggehen?
Bitte, mach.
Ich hab sie jetzt leicht schlecht, also insgesamt als schlecht eingeschätzt.
Geh ich komplett mit.
Ich find's krass. Das sieht man dann ja auch in unseren All-Star-Teams. Sie sind mehrmals in den Aufstiegsringen dabei. Also ich glaube, wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, drei Leute tippen sie unter den ersten drei. Und das sehe ich nicht. Das sehe ich wirklich beileibe nicht. Ich finde es auch interessant, dass Thorsten Lieberknecht sehr offensiv davon spricht, dass man sagt, ja, keiner tippt uns da noch oben rein, aber wir haben den Traumaufstieg und das wollen wir dieses Jahr schaffen. Das sehe ich nicht. Das hängt mit mehreren Faktoren zusammen. Ich fand jetzt die Spiele von Lieberknecht, die ersten, die ich unter ihm gesehen habe, in Kassaslautern nicht überzeugend. Damit fängt es mal an. Sie haben mit Ragnar Aache einen der besten Spieler dieser Liga verloren und mit Karloč einen stillen Helden dieses Kaders. Ich fand ihn für das Mittelfeld schon echt wichtig. Sie haben dafür Spieler gewonnen. Semisahin, Kunze, Pretaljen, Emreli. Das sind Spieler, die definitiv gut in der 2. Liga sind. Aber für mich ist Kassaslautern, wenn ich das mit der letzten Saison vergleiche und auch mit dem Fußball von Markus Anfang vergleiche, das ist so viel biederer. Das muss nicht gleich unerfolgreicher sein. Aber insgesamt, wenn ich mir Trainer, Erwartungshalt und Kader angucke, irgendwie passt das für mich nicht zusammen. Und ich glaube, dass auch da– ich will Kassaslautern nicht unten reinreden, um Gottes willen– das ja völlig vermessen. Aber ich glaube, die werden am Ende vielleicht in der oberen Tabellenhefte dann vielleicht einen Tabellen-Mittelfeldplatz holen. Und dann sehe ich da auch nicht viel mehr. Aber wie siehst du es denn, Eva?
Nee, ich gehe da tatsächlich komplett mit. Also ich mag Thorsten Lieberknecht, der kann auch echt was schaffen. Aber dieser Kara passt für mich nicht. Also der passt einfach nicht. Und ehrlich gesagt, genau aus den Gründen, die du gerade aufgezählt hast. Ich habe sie auch von auf circa gleich bis schlechter getippt, was denke ich okay ist. Aber, ja, also klar, ein Spiel brauchst du es nicht dran zu messen. Das haben wir schon öfter gesagt. Aber da muss für mich gerade Offensiv viel mehr kommen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie viel mehr halt können. Ich habe halt so das Gefühl, das ist halt trotzdem in weiten Teilen ein Zweitliga-Kader, der vor zwei, drei Jahren um einiges besser performt hätte. Aber jetzt halt durchaus einige Spieler in sich, die halt schon ein bisschen unter ihrem Niveau kicken. Also im Sinne von oder einfach unter ihren Erwartungen zurückbleiben. Und ich glaube, das beschreibt dein Kaiserslaut am Ende des Tages für mich auch gut. Da steckt eine absolute Wucht hinter in diesem Verein. Du merkst, wenn es da mal läuft, auch im Schatten dieses Pokalfinals. Da kann echt viel passieren. Aber ich habe, also wilde These, aber ich habe bis heute auch immer noch das Gefühl, dass das Erreichen dieses Pokalfinals vielleicht auch manche Sichtweisen auf den Kader zu unsichtbar machen lassen, Probleme. Und die hat man für mich letzte Saison nicht behoben, was man natürlich auch sehen könnte an, wie die Saison gelaufen ist, mit dem Trainer wechselt. Und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass man die zu dieser Saison stand jetzt, muss man ja dann doch immer sagen, weil wir eben Vortransferschluss aufnehmen. Passt es nicht, nee. Gut.
Und dann sind wir bei der nächsten Partie.
Ja, bei Magdeburg gegen Eintracht Braunschweig und Braunschweig. Die können direkt zu Beginn drei wichtige Punkte als einziges Auswärtsteam an diesem Spieltag mit nach Hause bringen. Ich glaube, für viele Leute durchaus überraschend, weil sie schon bei vielen Teams eben trotz der gewonnenen Relegation relativ weit unten sind. Man muss sagen, also absolute Energieleistung, vor allem trotz einer fast kompletten Halbzeit in Unterzahl. Magdeburg auf dem Papier vielleicht mit mehr Chancen und Spielanteilen. Aber ehrlich gesagt hat sich das viel zu harmlos nach vorne, vor allem in Überzahl hatte man das Gefühl, ja Braunschweig steht da als Bollwerk, aber sie haben kaum kreative Wege drum herum gefunden. Und am Ende macht es mir mit Aydin aus 32 Metern eben zum 1 zu 0. Absolut schönes Tor und man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, in Unterzahl musst du es auch mal genauso versuchen. Marc, lass uns doch vielleicht mal tatsächlich mit Magdeburg reinstarten. Was ist da deine Tendenz?
Ja, ich kann sagen, der Spieltag hat sie auf jeden Fall bestätigt, denn ich kann so vorweggreifen für mich in meiner Tabelle oder in meinen Top- und Flop-3 werden sie Tabellen 16. Ich habe gar kein gutes Gefühl bei Magdeburg diese Saison. Auch da der große Faktor Trainer. Du hast mit Christian Titz den Macher des Erfolgs der letzten Jahre verloren, der diesem Kader so viel Identität gegeben hat und diesen Kader auch permanent überperformen lassen hat. Du hast nie in der Saison auf diesen Kader erst geguckt und gedacht, naja, da müssen sie ja oben mitspielen. Das war die Arbeit von Christian Titz mit diesem Kader. Und nun ist es Markus Fiedler, zu dem ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel sagen kann. Auch der, der muss gute Arbeit in Stuttgart gemacht haben. Definitiv gilt als großes Trainer-Talent. Aber auch er ist ein absoluter Neuling in dieser Liga. Er ist 39 Jahre alt. Und das ist der eine Faktor, der aber nun mal der größte ist. Die Trainer-Personal, das sage ich dir verantwortlich immer wieder, ist die wichtigste im Verein. Und da hat man sich in meinen Augen erstmal, klar, verschlechtert. Das ist der eine Punkt. Und das andere ist die Transferphase. Ich finde, wenn schon der Trainer nicht überzeugen kann, dann muss es die Transferphase eigentlich tun. Und da erlebe ich so gar keine Wucht. Du hast mit Elhan Kouri einen wichtigen Spieler der letzten Saison verloren. Aber auch Livan Burcu, der jetzt bei Union wieder ist. Also zwei wirklich wichtige Spieler hast du verloren. Und du hast Spieler geholt wie Laurin Ulrich, Noa Pesc. Super junge Spieler, die die 2. Liga überhaupt nicht kennen und auch erstmal funktionieren müssen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Magdeburg dieses Jahr ein so stabiles Gebilde sein wird, als dass diese Spieler funktionieren. Und der dritte Faktor für mich ist, die Spieler, die es in den letzten Jahren oft gerissen haben, die werden auch nicht jünger. Und ich finde, das sieht man auch an barisch-artig. Ich will jetzt noch nicht den Abgesang auf barisch-artig starten. Der ist 30 Jahre alt. Aber ich finde, wir sehen– Wir haben letzte Saison schon nicht mehr den selben barisch-artig erlebt, wie in der Saison davor. Und es würde mich wundern, wenn es passiert. Und ich frage mich, ob die Vertragsverlängerung von ihm nicht dahingehend sogar ein Indiz ist, dass man da nicht mehr so viel erwarten kann, wie in den Jahren zuvor, weil er auch weiß, ey, ich setze mich hier ins gemachte Netz. Ich weiß, ich bin hier der Unterschiedspieler. Ich darf hier kicken. Alles gut. Und dazu kommt– also für mich ist überhaupt nicht gesetzt, dass Martin K wieder 19 Mal knipst.
Wenn er denn bleibt, wenn ich gesagt habe. Da gab es ja auch genug Diskussionen jetzt.
Das ist ein weiterer Faktor, wenn er denn bleibt. Aber selbst wenn er bleibt, der hatte jetzt eine Super-Saison, Tore-mäßig. Aber für mich ist nicht entschieden, dass er das jetzt direkt wiederholen kann. Also so gut kenne ich ihn auf diesem Niveau noch nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass auch da so ein bisschen wie bei Elbersberg sich einfach so eine Negativ-Spirale entwickeln könnte, aus der sie sich nicht so richtig befreien können. Und dann ist die Liga so eng, dass du Spiel um Spiel vielleicht knapp verlierst. Ich glaube nicht, dass die die werden nie null viel verlieren und du fragst dich, was ist denn mit denen los? Dafür ist die Axis zu scharfil, aber ich sehe die in so vielen direkten Duellen erstmal nicht als Favoriten. Und ich glaube, dass sich daraus eine Eigendynamik entwickeln könnte, die eklig wird.
Ja, da gehe ich tatsächlich mit. Es ist natürlich auch kein gutes Ohm, dass man das erste Heimspiel und eben als einziger Liga-Vertreter an diesem Spieltag eben direkt das Heimspiel wieder verliert. Und das war ja das große, große Problem in der letzten Saison, dass man das einen eben dran gehindert hat, ja wirklich auch potenziell aufzusteigen. Also eben weil man zu Hause die Punkte nicht holen konnte, auswärts das beste Team war, aber eben zu Hause die Punkte gelassen hat. Und so rein zu starten, muss ich auch einfach ganz– also ich mag den Standort Magdeburg, ich mag die Fans größtenteils, ich mag, was die mitbringen in die Liga generell. Ich finde, also das soll auch nicht zu pathetisch klingen, aber ich finde generell schön, wenn wir eben auch mehr, ja, Aufteilung haben an Vereinen in der Liga. Also nicht, also du hast ja jetzt im Prinzip eigentlich so ein bisschen die A2-Liga, du fährst ja immer die A2 lang und hast irgendwie– Die Elf-Freunde jetzt auch einen schönen Artikel, ja. Genau, Shoutout an Luis Richter. Du fährst ja quasi einmal die Linie durch. Ich mag das eigentlich, wenn du so ein bisschen durchmischter hast und irgendwie aus allen Bundesländern ein bisschen und eben dann eben auch aus dem Osten halt ein paar mehr Vereine. Bin ich per se erstmal Fan von, muss ich dazu sagen. Aber man muss halt einfach sagen, ich gehe da eben mit. Das wird nicht, das wird richtig schwierig. Für mich sind sie kein Absteiger. Das liegt aber weniger an ihnen und mehr als an den Vereinen, die ich unter ihnen sehe und ja. Also ich hatte auch das Gefühl, schon in diesem ersten Spiel war sehr, sehr viel Frustration zum Teil dabei und Markus Fiedler ist so. Ich habe ja einfach immer den Vorteil, dass ich dieses Team gesehen habe, Stuttgart 2. Aber man muss halt auch einfach sagen, es ist einfach was komplett anderes, mit einer Zweitvertretung in der dritten Liga zu spielen, als mit einer Mannschaft, mit so viel Tradition, mit durchaus auch Fans, die sich wünschen, irgendwie mal doch irgendwann ein paar Bundesliga zu spielen. Ja, das da, also ja, sehe ich nicht. Punkt.
Dann kommen wir zu einem anderen Zweitliganeuling. Oder wolltest du noch einen abschließenden Satz sagen zu Magdeburg?
Nee, ich wollte tatsächlich rüber wechseln zu Eintracht Braunschweig.
Dann kommen wir zu einem weiteren Liganeuling, nämlich Heiner Backhaus von Alemannia Aachen mit viel Getöse. Aber das ist ein eigenes Thema. Nach Braunschweig gekommen, 43 Jahre alt. Und er hat jetzt dieses Duell der Trainerneulinge gewonnen. Und ja, also ich habe Braunschweig als In-Etwa-Gleichgut eingeschätzt und ich habe sie nicht auf einen direkten Abstiegsplatz oder auch auf Platz 16 getippt. Ich glaube, die hieven sich tatsächlich dieses Jahr. Also bei Braunschweig geht es für mich dieses Jahr auch nur um Platz 15, 14, 13. Aber ich glaube, dass die es packen könnten, weil ich gut finde, also ich finde, dass sowohl auf der Trainerposition als auch bei den Transfers, das wirkt wie eine Frischzellenkur. Also sie haben sich von vielen Altlasten getrennt. Dazu zählt definitiv nicht Rayan Philipp, der Faktor war, dass also sein Abgang ist der Faktor für mich, warum ich sage, sie sind nicht besser als letztes Jahr, sondern sind vergleichlich gut, weil das musst du erst mal verkraften, so ein Abgang, das war der Unterschiedspieler für Braunschweig. Aber sie haben, wie ich finde, eine gute Transferperiode bisher hingelegt. Also du holst mit Ron-Torben Hoffmann den Toyota Fest, der letztes Jahr mit dafür gesorgt hat, dass du in der Liga geblieben bist, hast diese Personale also mal frühzeitig geklärt. Dasselbe mit Lino Tempelmann, der jetzt fest verpflichtet wurde und den Schalke 3er-Pack macht dann eben mehr mit einliegen, der definitiv der Spieler des Spiels war gegen Magdeburg. Irre viel geleistet in dem Spiel und auch das Tor geschossen. Ich finde, für Braunschweig ist das ein mehr zu lieder Rechtsverteidiger oder ein rechter Schienenspieler in dem Fall. Robin Heuser, ich habe nicht verstanden, warum der nicht in Karlsruhe funktioniert hat, weil ich den bei Wiesbaden herausragend gut fand. Und ich glaube, dass der bei Braunschweig, wenn er da absolut gesetzt ist, echt super gut sein kann. Ja, und auch Jadim Schi, der passt an sich als Philipp Ersatz, weil der ist super schnell und spielerisch gut. Also das, was Philipp ja auch ausmacht, das hat Jadim Schi drin. Aber natürlich junger Spieler, noch nicht lange in Deutschland. Das muss erstmal funktionieren. Aber das Potenzial sehe ich so. Und deswegen finde ich, die Spieler, sie haben junge Spieler geholt, die mal ein bisschen hungriger sein könnten. Sie haben mit Baccarus einen Trainer, das hat man in diesem Spiel gesehen, der erfindet den Fußball nicht neu. Das ist kämpfen, kreisen, kämpfen, beißen, kratzen. Aber finde ich irgendwie den Tick mutiger, den Tick offensiver, als es vielleicht unter vorherigen Trainern der Fall war. Und ich glaube, sie werden einfach nochmal unangenehmer sein, als vielleicht andere Braunschweigermannschaften der Vorjahre. Und ich glaube, dass das ein paar Prozentpunkte ausmachen könnte. Das ist immer noch kein guter Kader im Zweitliga-Vergleich. Und deswegen bleibe ich dabei, die werden um Platz 15 rum mitspielen. Aber ich glaube, dass sie vielleicht dieses Jahr ein etwas besseres Momentum entwickeln könnten. Und das hat dieses erste Spiel für mich unterstrichen. Sie könnten etwas mutiger agieren als in der Vergangenheit. Und das braucht Braunschweig, weil dieses Herummeandern in den letzten Jahren, das nervt selbst mich von außen, wo ich denke, was wollt ihr denn sein? Warum hieft ihr euch von Jahr zu Jahr und habt keine Vision? Das fand ich jedes Jahr anstrengend. Da wird mir, glaube ich, Anna Lautenbach absolut zustimmen. Und ich habe jetzt in diesem Sommer mal das Gefühl gehabt, ach Mensch, man denkt ja über ein Jahr hinaus, was Trainer und Kader angeht. Und das stimmt mich leicht positiv.
Ja, da gehe ich auf jeden Fall mit. Also für mich, ja, ich habe sie auch jetzt ungefähr gleich bis leicht besser. Ist ja auch nicht sonderlich schwierig, ehrlich gesagt. Als in der Vorsaison bei Heiner Backhaus bin ich mir nicht vollständig sicher. Also auch da, er hat ein Jahr dritte Liga als Trainer verantwortet, bevor für ihn jetzt eben auch der Sprung in die 2. Liga anstand. Ich glaube, er ist eben genau, was du gesagt hast, so jemand für die Intensität. Und da muss man einfach sagen, hat Braunschweig vieles auf den Platz gebracht, was man eben durchaus vermisst hat, einfach was einfach gefehlt hat in der letzten Saison. Gut, man muss es nicht direkt so übertreiben wie Elas, der da vollkommen zurecht mit Rot vorm Platz fliegt. Also da hat gar nichts gepasst vom Timing her. Aber man muss einfach sagen, ne, passt. Und man muss ja auch einfach sagen, du hast eben gesagt, Altlasten, ne. Und wenn man mal guckt, keiner dieser Altlasten, gewissenteils, also klar, Ryan Philipp ist halt zum Heiß-Vor-Gegangenen, ist keine Altlast. Der Rest, der hat halt auch noch keinen neuen Verein, ne. Und das ist halt, ohne denen da zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber ich finde es auch wirklich, also sich von Ermin Bicacic zu trennen, wird kein einfacher Schritt gewesen sein. Ich glaube, das muss man auch sagen. Einfach, wenn man weiß, okay, der hat hier halt einfach so ein Stück Identität wieder in den Verein gebracht. Aber man musste halt einfach sagen, ne, aber wir müssen jetzt den Cut setzen. Und da kann halt so jemand einfach auf Jeroen Torben, Hoffmann, Lino Tempelmann, die eben, ja gerade Hoffmann, dieser komische Stint da mit Schalke dann schon ausgeliehen und jetzt eben wieder festgeholt. Die können halt für neue Identifikationen sorgen. Ich muss sagen, ganz dringend, ich muss sagen, ich vergesse permanent Sebastian Polter. Ich vergesse einfach, dass der noch Fußball spielt. Da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube, das vergisst er manchmal auch.
Aber ja, also ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was wir sehen. Aber ich muss halt auch wirklich sagen, ich will jetzt auch eine Entwicklung sehen. Ich möchte auch von Braunschweig jetzt eine Entwicklung sehen. Und ich glaube, da sprechen wir eben auch für Anna und da sprechen wir auch für alle Eintracht-Fans, weil es ist einfach irgendwann anstrengend, Jahr für Jahr gegen den Abstieg zu spielen. Und du das Gefühl hast, wir wissen vom ersten Spieltag, es wird wieder dahin gehen. Und wir wissen auch, das wird in der Winterpause nicht besser sein. Und ich glaube schon, dass sie in dieser Saison um einiges früher den Klassenerhalt festmachen könnten. Aber ich bin da mal sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir hinten raus sehen. Weil man muss auch sagen, es ist halt auch wieder ein Risiko mit Heiner Backhaus. Aber da sind sie halt im Vorteil, sie sind nicht alleine damit.
Ja, und immerhin ist da mal wieder was Lebendiges. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr, welcher Spieler das war, der eine ziemliche Generalkritik nach der Saison dargelassen hat, was auch Trainingsbedingungen und so angeht und sagt, dieser Verein ist eingestaubt. Das muss jetzt einfach mal aufgelockert werden. Dafür ist Heiner Backhaus, glaube ich, der Richtige. Ich weiß nicht, ob der sich über viele Jahre trägt. Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht eine ganz bewusste Entscheidung, von Jahr zu Jahr zu einem anderen Verein zu hoppen. Aber für den ersten Moment ist der, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht. So, und dann sind wir bei der allerletzten Partie dieses Spieltags. Na Mensch, haben wir es doch mal geschafft.
Lohnt unser anderthalb Stunden Projekt so lang richtig gut gehalten. Wer guck oder zauert wach?
Naja, ach, die Leute freuen sich. Erste Sendung, viel Futter ist doch schön. Und dann sind wir nämlich bei Fyrth und Dresden. Ja, auch ein flippiges Duell. Fyrth gewinnt am Ende 3 zu 2. Ja, schon flippig.
Er benutzt dieses Wort unter 50.
Büromonis benutzen das Wort. Wir müssen die abholen. Wir müssen unsere, wir müssen die Reichweite auch in gewisse Zielgruppen führen. Fyrth gewinnt hier ja auf jeden Fall 3 zu 2 gegen Dresden. Und das war wirklich eine wilde Partie. Das vielleicht wildeste Duell des ersten Spieltags. Fyrth ging nach nur 20 Sekunden in den Führungen. Futtkoi ist der Torschütze. Nach neun Minuten legt man das 2 zu 0 nach. Dynamo antwortet direkt mit einem 2 zu 1 durch Herferner. Und dann liegt das Momentum schon bei Dresden. Aber es kamen erst mal keine Tore. Und nach dem Pausen geht es erst mal direkt so weiter. Denn direkt wieder Fyrth, direkt wieder schnell und direkt wieder Futtkoi. In 51 Minuten das 3 zu 1. Da lässt er gleich drei D-Sner-Defensivspieler stehen, dupiert die Regel recht. Und auch dann, Dresden kommt wieder, baut sich Momentum auf, will und kommt auch mit dem 3 zu 2 durch Kammerknecht auch noch mal ran. Aber trotz all des Drückens kommt am Ende kein 3 zu 3 raus. Und so holt Fyrth tatsächlich den ersten Sieg der Saison. Und das ist ein Signal, denn Fyrth ist, glaube ich, auch eine Black Box. In diesem Riesenumbruch und mit diesem wirklich schlimmen letzten Jahr. Und ja, was machen wir denn jetzt erst mal aus Dresden, aus dem Spiel, Eva?
Boah, gute Frage. Also auch da bin ich ja relativ nah dran gewesen. Ich muss einfach sagen, es ist vielleicht nicht ganz fair, weil es ist wirklich sehr interessant. In unserem Old-State-Team hat niemand Bielefeld als Absteiger getippt, aber durchaus viele Dresden.
Unter anderem ich, ich bekenne mich schuldig.
Ja, ich mich tatsächlich auch, was überhaupt nichts gegen Dresden ist. Aber ja, sie haben super interessante Spieler. Also ich glaube gerade Konrad Fahbar, dem man eben, es könnte ein absoluter Unterschiedspieler sein.
Aber er jetzt im ersten Spiel defensiv wirklich schlimm war. Beide Tore fallen über seine Seite.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Ding an Dynamo Dresden. So gut sie in der Offensive sind, desto Probleme haben sie durchaus in der Defensive. Das hat sich auch zum Teil in der dritten Liga durchgezogen. Man muss sagen, diese letzte Drittligasaison war Vogelwild. Ich glaube auch, dass das zum Teil noch nachgehangen hat bei Dynamo-Spielern, dass man eben diese Meisterschaft dann eben noch vergeben hat. Und ich glaube also, für mich ist Dresden eine Mannschaft, die ganz, ganz viel durch Emotionalität lebt. Und das kann in beide Richtungen laufen. Also das kann einfach– und das hast du bis zu weiten Strecken eben gesehen in diesem Spiel, diese beiden Extreme zu– oh, wir kriegen direkt einen Dämpfer, wir kommen überhaupt gar nichts ins Spiel bis zu– aber wenn wir aber an Hoffnung schnuppern, dann sind wir auch da, und dann können wir den Gegner auch unter Druck setzen. Das hast du an Dresden halt diese Breite. Ich weiß nicht so ganz– also ich weiß schon, woher das, glaube ich, kommt, dass viele sie als Absteiger sehen, weil man einfach weniger von ihnen gesehen hat, als von Bielefeld, vor allem im direkten Vergleich halt mit Teams aus der Bundesliga und mit der 2. Liga. Das ist einfach so, das ist sicherlich nicht auch ganz fair. Aber ich glaube, also du hast einen Christoph Daferner, jemand, der gefühlt wirklich nur bei Dynamo Dresden funktioniert, nirgendwo anders, weder bei Nürnberg noch bei Düsseldorf, was natürlich auch für Dynamo spricht. Aber ich sehe da einfach Probleme und diese Probleme hast du einfach im Spiel gegen Fürth gesehen. Also, dass man eben sich diese– und ich meine, also wir werden gleich noch über Fürth sprechen– sprechen per se über eine Mannschaft, von der viele auch denken, dass das für die richtig schwierig werden könnte. Und ich bin mal gespannt, wenn Vincent Vermeid tatsächlich nach Dresden wechseln könnte das nochmal einen anderen Schwung reinbringen. Aber ich glaube, es ist ja schon so bei Dresden, da ist ein bisschen mehr Zweitliga-Erfahrung drin. Die Mannschaft ist per se, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen älter als die von Bielefeld.
Ich würde älter unterschreiben, aber nicht Zweitliga-Erfahrer. Ich finde, dass in der Mannschaft gibt es wenig Zweitliga-Erfahrungen. Rossi Pall, der hat sie bei Rostock ein bisschen gesammelt und auch Nils Fröhling bei Rostock. Und ansonsten wird es dünn, also da ferner. Gut, aber viel sind tatsächlich Spieler, die…
Stefan Kutschke, der hat doch auch schon bei Dresden gespielt, als sie die 2. Liga gespielt haben, oder?
Ja, aber war das so viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau.
Ich gucke jetzt live nach. Wir fact-checken, der Mann hat 124 Zweitliga-Spiele. Okay, das letzte Mal, 2022, ist ein bisschen her. Naja, aber ich finde, ich würde nicht unbedingt unterschreiben, dass das eine Zweitliga-erfahrene Truppe ist.
Nee, nicht erfahren, erfahren näher als gezwungen.
Okay, dann sind wir auf einer Seite. Ja, also ich habe Dresden tatsächlich als direkten Absteiger getippt. Das liegt daran, dass mich die Transferphase bislang überhaupt nicht überzeugt. Ich finde, sie haben wenig an Qualität und wenig an Zweitliga-Erfahrung dazugewonnen. Wie gesagt, Doppelpack aus Rostock mit Rossi Pall und Fröhling, aber die sind auch nicht ohne Grund einmal auch sehr klarklangungsabgestiegen mit Rostock. Gut, sie haben keine Spieler aus dem Aufstiegserfolgskader verloren, außer, das ist wichtig, Jonas Sterner. Der war letzte Saison mit der beste Rechtsverteidiger der dritten Liga. Der ist jetzt auch zu fest zu Hannover gewechselt, war von Kiel ausgeliehen und dafür ist jetzt eben Faber gekommen. Mal sehen, ob er das ersetzen kann. Ich habe das Gefühl, so was ich mir auch angelesen habe und so, dass Dresden letzte Saison sehr über eine sehr wuchtige, dominant Spielweise reingekommen ist, die aber auch ein bisschen– es mag vielleicht sehr wertenklingen– sehr stumpf daher kam. Also man hat halt einfach Vollgas-Fußball gespielt, permanent. Und ich weiß nicht, ob man die individuelle Qualität jetzt in Zweitländer vergleicht hat, um seine Gegner gleich zu erdrücken. Jetzt gegen Fürth hat man Druck entwinkeln können, aber das liegt vielleicht auch einfach an einer Fürther-Mannschaft, die neu zusammengewürfelt ist und letzte Saison auch den Abschied gespielt hat und vielleicht daher noch nicht so gefestigt daherkam und das mit sich machen lässt, wenn sie dann führt. Aber ich habe erhebliche Zweifel daran, dass diese Spielweise funktioniert wird. Man hat sehr viel Vertrauen im Trainer Thomas Stamm, hat nach Vorsaison statt den Vertrag verlängert. Ruhe dahingehend bringt sicherlich was, aber du hast es schon gesagt, sehr imbezügliches Umfeld. Lass die mal die ersten 6, 7 Spiele verlieren. Ich glaube, dann wird es unruhig in Dresden. Die haben ohnehin einen leichten Knacks weg, weil sie seit Jahren eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft sind. Sie kennen das jetzt auch nicht, dass man dann vielleicht ein paar Spiele verliert und trotzdem in der Liga bleiben kann. Das war zuletzt eher kein gutes Umfeld, wenn das so angefangen hat. Diese euphoriehende Zusammenhalt, die können natürlich auch, ähnlich wie bei Bielefeld, auch für neue Höhen sorgen, dass man dann mit dieser Heimwucht vor allem Spiele gewinnt, die man eigentlich sonst nicht gewinnen würde. Aber ich gucke ganz neutral, berechnend auf diesen Kader und sage, das ist vielleicht der schlechteste Kader, vielleicht der schlechteste, das ist hart, aber es ist einer der schlechtesten Kader, individuell gesehen, in dieser Liga, wie ich finde. Und die können mich alle gerne überraschen. Und Dresden ist ein weiteres Essert in dieser Liga, ein weiterer totaler Zugewinn. Wäre schön, wenn die drin bleiben. Aber ich stand jetzt ein bisschen schwer, vor allem, wie du sagst, defensiv. Denn das war gegen Fürth gruselig defensiv.
Ja, das verstehe ich total. Und natürlich ein großes Fragezeichen, auch hinter Thomas Stamm. Also ich mag ihn als Trainer. Ich finde eigentlich, also nach Markus Anfang, ich war mir nicht sicher, wie er es schafft bei Dynamo Dresden. Also es war ja auch letzte Saison erst. Also erst seine erste Saison als Dynamo-Coach. Das hätte absolut in beide Wege für mich gehen können, weil du eben halt mit jemandem wie Stefan Kutschke halt jemand im Kader hast, der glaube ich durchaus sehr, sehr viel zu sagen hat. Obwohl er nicht mehr viel Spielzeit hat. Und sowohl ein Vorteil als auch ein Nachteil sein kann in diesem Team. Aber man muss halt auch sagen, also Stammtrainerkarriere ist nicht kurz, aber halt im Profifußball ist er kurz. Also er war eben lange Freiburg und 19 Trainer, dann war er drei Jahre lang Trainer von Freiburgs zweiter Mannschaft. Und jetzt eben dann für Dynamo Dresden, also auch der Sprung zu Dresden, war natürlich ein unglaublich großer, ehrlich gesagt ähnlich wie halt bei Kniet. Auch Kniet hat halt den Vorteil, dass er ein Jahr mehr unter Aminia mitgemacht hat und eben mit Aminia auch diesen Abstiegskampf im ersten Jahr mitgemacht hat. Und ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, was bei vielen Bielefeld-Fans halt so im Hinterkopf ist und vielleicht auch bei anderen. Von daher, ja, das ist nur mein Gedanke noch dazu. Aber generell, ja, also ich glaube einfach, die Art und Weise, wie Dresden zum Ende der Saison und halt auch immer in der dritten Liga davor zum Ende der Saison agiert hat, dass sie es eben zweimal hintereinander verpasst haben, auch mit dem Ausstieg. Das sind halt alles so Sachen, die werden auch eben bei den Fans im Hinterkopf sein, Entschuldigung. Und da bin ich daher auch, ja, ich bin gespannt. Also ich meine, ich muss auch da sagen, prinzipiell können die auch noch ein Jahr in der Zwei-Liga spielen. Also so ist es nicht. Weil ich glaube, ein erneuter Abstieg wird halt auch richtig wehtun.
Du merkst aber, ich finde, ich dem Kader einfach an, die waren drei Jahre weg. Und ich finde, das merkst du dem Kader so langsam an. Es fehlen so Unterschiedsspiele auf Zweitliganiveau, wie ich finde.
Ja, da sind wir da mal, glaube ich, ziemlich gespannt. Und ich würde sagen, Marc, damit beenden wir unsere… Nein, nein, nein, nein, nur die Vorschau. Oder habe ich erführt?
Der erste Eklat dieser Rasenfunkstaffel, da wollte ich einfach fürz kippen.
Oh Gott, ist das unangenehm. Entschuldigung.
Ach, passiert.
Ich muss da zu meiner Verteidigung sagen, Dresden steht bei mir als letzte Stelle. Und deshalb habe ich sie jetzt einfach übersprungen. Entschuldigung, Marc, bitte.
Sehr schön.
So, wir holen einfach Michi Fischer in vielleicht die nächste Sendung. Kann er das ausgleichen. Also, hört. So, die letzte Black Box dieser Folge. Massiven Umbruch gehabt. Also, Gefühl 20 Spieler rein, 20 Spieler raus.
Der SV Sandhausen-Weg.
So ein bisschen, ja. Und mit Thomas Kleiner auch nach wie vor ja ein Unerf- Ich bin ein sehr gut verahrenden Coach, zumindest auf der Chef-Trainer-Position, der letzte Saison ja auch nur noch quasi, also sie in der Liga gehalten hat, fair enough, aber jetzt keine ganze Saison moderiert halt als Stammtrainer. Also auch da finde ich immer noch ein neues Gesicht ist. Dementsprechend einfach sehr viele Faktoren. Ich finde einige Dinge des Kaderumbruchs gut. Also ich finde, dass sie mit Aaron Keller einen super spannenden Spieler dazu gewonnen haben. Olesen, Dehm, Ziereis, das sind alles für mich erst mal Spieler, die auf zweitiger Niveau funktionieren sollten. Ich bin mir recht sicher, dass die Verantwortlichen viele Lehren aus der letzten Saison gezogen haben. Fürth halte ich auch insgesamt für besser als im Vorjahr. Und auch da geht das Schalke-Argument. Es kann auch wirklich nicht mehr schlechter werden. Das war wirklich eine so miese Saison. Das kann man kaum in Worte fassen. Das hat zum Bruch zwischen Mannschaft und Fans geführt. Das ist immer das schlimmste Signal, was es geben kann. Sie hätten letztes Jahr ein verdienter Absteiger sein können. Sie sind es nicht gewesen aufgrund der Konkurrenz. Ich glaube, das war vielleicht der Warnschuss, den sie gebraucht haben. Bei Fyrt sehe ich nicht mehr als Platz 12 in diesem Jahr. Das sage ich auch. Für mich geht es nicht darum, dass sie jetzt irgendwie durchrasieren, um Gottes willen. Aber ich finde den Kader vielleicht auch ausgewogener als im Vorjahr. Sie haben sich vielleicht mit Leuten wie Felix Hiegel auch vielleicht ein paar ganz gute Charaktere in die Mannschaft geholt, die mehr Verantwortung nehmen wollen. Sie haben jetzt mit Bo Wink auch einen erfahrenen Kader im Kasten. Vielleicht tut das auch mal gut. Neu spielt er jetzt in Hannover, passt vielleicht auch besser zum Stil von Titz. Deswegen finde ich den Kader insgesamt ein bisschen ausgewogener. Ich finde ihn immer noch nicht gut. Deswegen glaube ich, dass sie im letzten Tabellendrittel landen werden. Aber ich glaube, dass sie vielleicht nicht ganz so stark reingezogen werden in den Abschiedskampf wie im letzten Jahr. Und das wäre doch schon ein Erfolg, nachdem es letztes Jahr wirklich schlimm war. Und damit bin ich auch fertig mit Fird.
Ich ergänze einmal kurz dazu. Drei bei uns aus dem Oldster-Team haben sie als Absteiger tatsächlich getippt in dieser Saison. Also auch da zumindest ein Viertel ist nicht vollkommen überzeugt.
Es tut mir leid.
Ich werde tatsächlich per se mitgehen von dem, was du gesagt hast. Also ich glaube, da gab es absolut notwendige Trennungen auch. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich sage jetzt etwas, was, glaube ich, durchaus kontrovers sein könnte. Ich glaube, man muss sich langsam aber sicher immer mal von Brandy Miriam-Gotha trennen.
Nein! Hergotha!
Weil, und ich glaube, das ist halt, auf denen setzt man relativ viel und er bringt halt auch immer noch seine Leistung. Ich hatte aber zuletzt auch immer das Gefühl, dass man sich ein bisschen zu sehr an Hergotha als Stütze in diesem Kader ausgeruht hat. Ich glaube, da gab es andere Vereine auch, wo man eben gesagt hat, der ist ja da und dann basteln wir drum herum. Ich glaube, diese Saison kann er das noch gut machen. Ich glaube aber, dass du tatsächlich irgendwann mal nach dieser Saison vielleicht auch sagen müsstest. Ich meine, dann ist der Mann auch 33, wenn ich das richtig rechne. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob man dann vielleicht mal sagen muss, nö. Also prinzipiell glaube ich, ja, es gibt definitiv Besserungen im Kader, leichte Verbesserungen, klar, viele Verletzungen, auch gerade jetzt noch vor Saisonstart. Ja, also ich glaube, ich stand jetzt auch in Keller verletzt, Sascha Banzé verletzt, Lukas Reich und Mark Ion. Genau, Mark Ion, eigentlich auch sehr interessant, weil der ja auch mal für mich mal so ein absolutes Talent da auf der linken Verteidigerposition galt.
Ja, der hatte echt eine gute Zeit mal in Hoffenheim und dann kam irgendwie nichts mehr.
Genau, also für mich eigentlich sehr interessanter Spieler, aber generell, also ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht, da übrigens in Verteidiger Luca Itta, wobei wir wieder bei Itta und Ittin wären.
Der war letzte Saison vielleicht noch einer der Lichtblicker tatsächlich.
Ja, auch der natürlich verletzt, also Verletztenliste ist relativ lang. Aber ja, ich bin auch mal gespannt. Ich glaube, ich habe, wie gesagt, leicht besser aus den gleichen Gründen, wie du gesagt hast, aber so vollständig überzeugend. Und ich meine, ja, da lief vieles für sie heute im Spiel. Das war offensiv gut, aber halt auch defensiv Vogelwelt. Also ich habe nach zehn Minuten gedacht, gut, also es können auch beide Mannschaften einfach ohne Defensive spielen. Dann wird das ein unterhaltsames Spiel, aber auch ein sehr anstrengendes Spiel.
Vielleicht hilft es der Mentalität aber dann auch oder der mentalen Komponente, wenn man so ein Spiel über die Zeit bringt.
Voll, voll. Aber man muss natürlich auch, also ohne jetzt Dynamo Dresden auch zu nahe zu treten. Aber es war halt auch ein Spiel gegen den Aussteiger. Es könnte, also lass mich kurz einmal nachgucken, gegen wen es jetzt als nächstes geht. King Eintracht Braunschweig.
Das wird interessant, weil wenn sie das Spiel auch gewinnen sollten, sage ich jetzt mal, dann hätten sie schon zwei Spiele gegen direkte Konkurrenten im Abschiedskampf. Und ich glaube, darum geht es eben für Fürth besiegt. Das wäre schon ein starker Start.
Genau. Und dann halt nach dem DFB-Pokal Holstein-Kiel, Magdeburg. Also nach unserer Regelung drei Vereine, die wir eben da unten mit rein sortieren. Von daher bin ich da auch sehr, sehr gespannt drauf, was wir davon sehen. Aber Marc darf ich jetzt sagen, wir sind am Ende der Saison-Prognosen, bis auf einen kleinen Fakt angekommen. Denn Marc und ich, wir haben so viel über unsere Tabellentipps diskutiert. Und wir wollen jetzt natürlich einmal nochmal richtig hören, was sind unsere ersten drei, was unsere letzten drei. Ganz kurz noch den Rest. Wir zählen jetzt nicht alle Tipps des restlichen All-Star-Teams aus. Da, wie gesagt, schaut doch bitte bei den sozialen Kanälen vorbei und im Forum, da werdet ihr das finden. Aber Marc, wer steigt für dich auf? Wer steigt ab?
Ja, wie gesagt, nach dem ersten Spieltag sieht das nicht so gut aus.
Heißt nix.
Aber meine Top-3 in richtiger Reihenfolge, also ich habe Hertha auf 1 getippt, ich habe Holstein Kiel auf 2 getippt und den VfL Bochum auf Platz 3. So, und bei meinen Absteigern habe ich Magdeburg auf 16, Elbersberg auf 17 und Dresden auf 18.
Ja, sehr schön. Ich habe Hannover auf 1, Karlsruhe auf 2, Fortuna Düsseldorf auf 3.
Das scheiden uns komplett. Krass.
Ja, aber ich finde es cool. Also ich muss auch sagen, mich haben die Tipps, ich fand es sehr witzig, die auch irgendwie einzugeben. Es waren ganz häufig die gleichen Pools an Namen, aber trotzdem immer in unterschiedlicher Reihenfolge. Dann habe ich die SVI auf Platz 16, Preuß Münster auf 17 und Dynamo Dresden auf 18.
Da gleichen wir uns sogar.
Genau, da sind wir tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so weit auseinander. Und ich würde sagen, damit sind wir ja am Ende dieser, durch aus etwas XXL-Folge angekommen, eine Mini-Großvorschau vom Rasenfunk. Aber wir dachten, wir sind euch noch ein bisschen was schuldig.
Eben.
Und wir wollen euch natürlich auch, weil es auch eben im Forum hieß, ja eine Vorschau wäre schön und es bei uns einfach zeitlich nicht reingepasst hat, vom ersten Spieltag das zu machen, wollten wir das zumindest für euch, irgendwie euch noch mit an den Weg geben, obwohl man natürlich immer sagen muss, nach dem ersten Spieltag zu sehen, war natürlich schon irgendwie nochmal ganz cool, um dem damit reinzunehmen, in manchen Bereichen. Hilft, hilft aber auch nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, Marc, das war eine schöne Premiere mit dir hier.
Ey voll. Leider werden wir uns jetzt wieder nicht sprechen wahrscheinlich, weil jetzt geht der normale Modus los, aber es hat mich total gefreut, diesen Anfang mit dir gemacht zu haben.
Ja, mich auf jeden Fall auch. Und ich würde sagen, vielleicht machen wir das noch mal zur Halbserie, dass wir da quasi noch mal zu zweit das Ganze abschließen. Das habe ich jetzt einfach mal in den Raum ohne Abstimmung gehauen. Schon mal als Info, es steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber eventuell die nächste Folge, die erscheint dann erst nach eben der DFB-Bukal-Pause, weil wir haben gesagt, wir brauchen nicht einen Spieltag später direkt wieder eine Folge aufzunehmen. Also wenn dann drei Spieltage gespielt sind, hört ihr uns wieder. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk, kommt gut in diese neue Woche, und wir hören uns bald wieder. Schön, dass wir zurück sind.
Macht's gut!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!